So, auf geht's.
Was passiert hier?
Das wüsste ich auch gerne, das frage ich mich jedes Mal.
Irgendeiner dreht seine Katze im Kreis.
So, ich habe übrigens was für einen Keller gekauft.
Es war ein Blutsensor.
Blutsensor, man weiß ja aktuell mit Überschwemmung nie.
Ich habe zwei Stück.
Ich habe einmal den da und dann habe ich noch Zigbee gekauft, weil das irgendwie nur ein Drittel gekostet hat.
Ich werde es im Keller liegen.
Wenn ich Überschwemmung im Keller habe, dann weiß ich Bescheid, dass ich Überschwemmung habe.
Was ich dagegen mache, ist wieder was anderes.
Aber ich weiß, dass ich dann Überschwemmung, also ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Gut.
Keck, wait, die Mod-Ansicht hat es nicht gerafft.
Outdated, jebaited, overrated Mod-Ansicht.
Also das Gute ist, das piepst sogar und es schickt über ZUF eine Benachrichtigung an die Heimautomatisierung, wenn es unter Wasser ist.
Ich habe das auch ausprobiert.
Ich habe einfach einen Teller, so ein Ding, Schüssel genommen, Wasser, habe das dann reingehalten.
Piep, piep, piep.
Geht automatisch eine Pumpe anspringen.
Schmeißen lassen.
Ja, das ist dann der nächste Schritt.
Das war natürlich Big Brain.
Muss man das dann auf einen Schrank drauf machen?
Nee, das legt man auf die Erde.
Das legt man dahin.
Das legt man dahin, wo man denkt, dass es nass wird.
Das hat unten Kontakte.
Hier sieht man es, guck mal.
Und ich glaube, wenn hier das Wasser drankommt, dann erkennst du das.
Dann diese Kontakte.
Doch, bei mir hast du eine Abo-Batch.
Abo-Bat-Gel.
Sat-Gel.
Bett-Gel.
Ja.
Das funktioniert.
Also ich habe es auch auf die Erde gestellt.
Wie gesagt, ich habe es in der Schüssel ausprobiert.
Funktioniert.
Ja.
Ich bin müde noch.
Residenz Lieber.
Aber ansonsten wie immer.
Übrigens, Leute, kennt ihr schon die neuste Verschwörungstheorie?
Ich musste heute Morgen richtig kecken, als ich das gelesen habe.
Neuste Verschwörungstheorie.
Gut, vielleicht bin ich auch nicht up-to-date und ihr sagt jetzt, Max, das ist ja schon, das ist outdated.
Also, das kennt ja schon jeder.
Und zwar, die, die neuste, ich musste kecken, ja.
Die neuste Verschwörungstheorie, die ich gelesen habe, ist, dass das Hoch, äh, nicht das, das, das Unwetter, beziehungsweise das Hochwasser in Deutschland,
dass das durch ein geheimes Wettermanipulationsprogramm der USA ausgelöst wurde.
Vielleicht ist das aber auch alt.
Vielleicht ist es, vielleicht bin ich einfach, vielleicht habe ich es erst.
Jetzt, jetzt, jetzt gesehen, vielleicht ist das ja auch schon uralt, aber, ja, also, äh, ich habe, ich habe einen Comment gelesen unter einem YouTube-Video, wo einer geschrieben hat,
die Leute tun ja immer so, als wäre das offensichtlichste und jeder weiß es schon, nur die Leute wollen es nicht wahrhaben.
Hat einer unter die, hat einer unter, hat einer unter, unter das Kommentar geschrieben, dass das ein geheimer, äh, Angriff irgendwie mit, mit dem Wetterprogramm der USA ist.
Will auch keiner wahrhaben, hat er reingeschrieben.
So nach dem Motto, das, das ist doch so offensichtlich.
Offensichtlich, dass es das ist.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was mit den Leuten los ist.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, jetzt, ich frage mich eher, was hätte die USA davon, das muss ich grundsätzlich sagen, was hätte die USA davon in, ähm, ich weiß gar nicht, wo das war.
Nordrhein-Westfalen, nee, wo waren die ganzen Überschwemmungen?
Was hätten die davon, wenn dort ein paar Häuser kaputt gehen?
Also, hä?
Ja, aber ich weiß nicht, wo das ist, wo ist das?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo das ist.
Ja, mit Versicherung finde ich ja auch.
Geil.
Ich habe einen, ich habe einen Beitrag gestern oder so gesehen, ähm, und da war direkt am Tag, das muss man sich mal vorstellen, das muss man sich mal vorstellen, da war direkt am Tag des Unwetters die Versicherung da und hat den, also direkt, wo ihr Haus kaputt gegangen ist, war die Versicherung da und hat gemeint, nee, also in Klausel 85 Absatz 2 ist das ausgeschlossen.
Wozu haben die den Scheiß gekauft, Alter?
Huge Cheap Aid.
Vor allem, das ist sehr feinfühlig.
Am Tag der Überschwemmung.
Direkt da hinzufahren und zu sagen, übrigens, Alter, ihr habt, ihr habt gelitten, ja.
Ach, gibt's, gibt's diese Verschwörungstheorie auch, dass wir das selbst ausgelöst haben, okay.
Wobei so, sagen wir mal, so weit von der Realität wird das gar nicht so weit weg sein, dass wir das selbst ausgelöst haben, zumindest indirekt, ja.
Also, es, wenn man sich mal anguckt, letztendlich sind da wahrscheinlich alle Industriestaaten der letzten 60 Jahre indirekt mit dran beteiligt.
Ich meine, klar, du weißt nie was ohne Klimawandel.
Sonst was wäre mit dem Wetter, ob's Überschwemmung, keine Ahnung.
Aber es ist schon nichts allzu weit hergeholt zu sagen, okay, das ist eines der Extremfälle, die damit was zu tun hat.
Und wer weiß, ne, also, indirekt haben wir da sicherlich zum Teil mit beigetragen.
Nee, da sind wir, da sind wir ja schon drüber raus.
Da sind wir ja schon drüber raus.
Also, dass es Klimawandel nicht gibt, sagt, glaube ich, keiner mehr.
Selbst die Hardcore-Verschwörungstheorie-Leute sagen das nicht mehr.
Äh, mittlerweile...
Ist eher die Frage, ist, ist es vom Mensch ausgelöst oder nicht?
Und da gibt's ja wirklich äußerst hitzige Diskussionen.
Dann hast du welche, die sagen, es ist die Sonne.
Dann hast du welche, die sagen, klar, es ist CO2.
Dann hast du, was, was hab ich letztens irgendwas, irgendwas gelesen mit...
Irgendwie der, total abgedrehtes Zeug, der Erdkern wird wärmer oder so Dinger.
Ach, was auch immer.
Also, ja, gut.
Aber ich finde das nachvollziehbar.
Also, ich finde, auf der einen Seite, ich...
Natürlich, uns betrifft's alle, ja.
Also, ich glaube, wir können uns da alle nicht rausreden und sagen, uns kann das egal sein.
Aber ich beobachte so Sachen immer gerne, weil eine Sache, die einem da schön dabei auffällt, ist,
dass umso einschneidender die Erlebnisse für die Leute sind, also, umso einschneidender die Auswirkung für irgendwas ist,
umso unlieber gestehen sich die Leute das ein, dass das passieren wird.
Man muss sich mal gucken, muss sich mal anschauen.
Es wurde ja schon vor...
Vor 60 Jahren oder wann auch immer das angekündigt, dass sich das so entwickeln wird.
Und das hat sich ja auch mehr oder weniger ähnlich, eher sogar noch schlechter entwickelt.
Also, das war zu sehen, aber das wurde einfach ganz lang ignoriert.
Und jetzt wird gesagt, ja gut, wir können ja nichts dran ändern, weil die Aussage, wir können nichts dran ändern,
ist natürlich super für jeden Einzelnen, der sagen kann, ja, da muss ich auch nichts machen.
Gut.
Wir da jetzt, was groß dran ändern können, das ist tatsächlich eine Frage, da kann man drüber diskutieren.
Wir haben ja nun weltweit nicht den allergrößten Einfluss da drauf.
Aber ich bin mir sicher, früher oder später, wahrscheinlich eher später,
bleibt den China-Chinesen auch nichts anderes übrig, als sich da was auszudenken.
Allerdings gehe ich ja davon aus, wir kriegen das überhaupt nicht gebacken.
Zumindest nicht in nächster Zeit und nicht so, dass es im Rahmen bleibt.
Das sind wir einfach zu schwerfällig für.
Äh, äh, also.
Max, habe noch eine Frage von gestern.
Wenn man in Debian den App-Config einfach testing steht, anstatt den Point-Release, dann hat man ein recht aktuelles Linux-Desktop.
Ja, kann man machen.
Äh, das habe ich nicht.
Ich habe, ich habe YAM mal Version-Log verwendet, aber das habe ich noch nie probiert mit Upt.
Was aber natürlich schon mal gar nicht funktioniert, da muss ich jetzt mal was dazu sagen.
Ich finde, ich finde den Ansatz, den wir hier teilweise haben, nicht sinnvoll.
Ja, wir zerfleischen uns bei so vielen Themen selber.
Anstatt da ordentlich drüber zu diskutieren.
Es geht, ich, ich will jetzt gar nicht, aber bleib, bleib mal bei dieser Klimawandel-Geschichte.
Also wir verschwenden sehr viel Zeit darauf, uns selbst gegenseitig zu zerfleischen.
Anstatt sich mal ordentlich Gedanken drüber zu machen.
Und ich habe auch gar kein Problem, wenn man mal Leute zu Wort kommen lässt, die es vielleicht anders sehen.
Weil ich finde, am besten kannst du Leute, die der Sache skeptisch gegenüberstehen, immer noch überzeugen.
Und indem du ihnen zeigst, okay, das, was euch da eigentlich vorschwebt, ergibt wenig Sinn.
Und das geht eigentlich nur, wenn du drüber redest und nicht, wenn du sagst, nee, nee, da mit solchen Leuten reden wir gar nicht.
Also du wirst keinen, der irgendwie an irgendwelche Verschwörungstheorien oder sonst was glaubt, jeder von überzeugen.
Indem du sagst, ihr seid es nicht wert, mit euch da drüber zu reden.
Das musst du eigentlich anders machen.
Du musst denn gerade mit den Leuten drüber reden und sagen, hey, das sind die einzigen, die du, vielleicht erreichst du noch ein paar.
Die meisten wirst du nicht mehr großartig erreichen können.
Was wir aber nicht machen können.
Und da, da fängt es, da fängt es ja schon an.
Also was wir nicht machen können ist, so wie sich das einige vorstellen, dass wir jetzt zurück in die Steinzeit gehen.
Das wird nicht funktionieren.
Und wisst ihr auch, warum das nicht funktionieren wird?
Wenn wir das jetzt machen, also wenn wir jetzt sagen, wir gehen jetzt zurück in die Steinzeit, ist übertrieben gesagt.
Niemand will mitmachen.
Niemand.
Warum sollte jemand mitmachen?
Die sehen bloß, okay, denen ging es mal ganz gut.
Die sind jetzt zurück in die Steinzeit und denen geht es jetzt schlecht.
Meint ihr, das macht irgendjemand nach?
Die sagen sich, oh fuck, guck mal, die haben es geschafft.
Die haben in den letzten Jahren sich komplett an den Arsch zu wirtschaften.
Da machen wir, das machen wir doch im Leben nicht nach.
Man müsste denen eigentlich eher zeigen, guck mal, man kann auch umweltbewusst und mit der nötigen Technik, die wir dann hätten, wenn wir ein bisschen zukunftsfähig denken würden, man kann trotzdem gut leben und umweltfreundlich sein.
Das ist eigentlich das, was mir meiner Meinung nach der Welt zeigen müsste, dass man sieht, okay, also beziehungsweise das ist das, wo wir als Land, was auch ordentlich Kohle, also Kohlegeld meine ich jetzt theoretisch hat, zeigen müssen, dass man sagen kann, okay, guck mal hier.
Okay.
Wir sind in der Lage, umweltfreundlich und mit Wohlstand zu leben, dann machen das auch andere Länder nach und wenn wir einfach zurück in die Steinzeit gehen, wie sich das manche Leute gerne vorstellen, dann wird es keinen interessieren.
Dann ist eher negativer Fall, dass die Leute sagen oder beziehungsweise andere Länder sagen, nö, machen wir nicht.
Warum sollte man das machen, wenn man zugeguckt hat, wie man es verkackt.
Aber ich bin echt mal gespannt.
Also ich beobachte, ich beobachte das.
Also von der Seitenlinie, die Diskussionen auf YouTube sind ja da auch richtig, schlagen ja immer hohe Wellen.
Aber was wirklich weniger geworden ist, die letzten 5, 6 Jahre über, Leute dieses komplett leugnen.
Das gibt es eigentlich nicht mehr.
Vor 5, 6 Jahren hat es so, ich habe auf der Arbeit übrigens auch einen Kollegen, habe ich euch ja schon mal erzählt, der war lange Zeit der Meinung, das gibt es nicht.
Und jetzt, also es gibt keinen Klimawandel und nix, das ist alles, wobei man sagen muss, der Typ ist nicht blöd.
Der hat früher beim Maxime...
Beim Max-Planck-Institut gearbeitet und beim, wie heißt das, irgendeinem anderen in Frankfurt, also der ist wirklich eigentlich relativ Big-Brain, der Typ.
Der hat die letzten Jahre über immer gesagt, ne, gibt es nicht.
Mittlerweile ist der aber auch auf dem Standpunkt, dass er sagt, ja, das gibt es, aber das liegt an, keine Ahnung, Sonnenaktivität und sonst was.
Meinetwegen.
Aber wenigstens sind wir jetzt schon so weit, dass eigentlich kaum noch einer sagt, gibt es gar nicht.
Naja.
So, aber genug unschöne Dinger.
Äh, ich, ja, ich sehe das übrigens auch, ähm, ich würde auch viel lieber Steuern bezahlen, wenn ich sehe, dass die irgendwo ankommen, wo ich, ähm, was, ne, wo ich sehe, dass da was, dass da was passiert.
Und nicht einfach nur in irgendein schwarzes Loch bezahlen, wo ich keinen blassen Schirm habe, was damit passiert.
Und eine Sache muss ich jetzt, ich muss einfach nochmal sagen, man sollte auch nicht im Sinne so von...
Klimawandel und sonstigen Sachen, man sollte auch nicht alles blind durchschwinken, weil es gibt immer, wenn es solche Katastrophen gibt und Sachen, die sich anbahnen, es gibt immer Leute, die sich bereichern wollen, an allen Ecken und Enden.
Meint ihr denn wirklich, dass alle Automobilkonzern-Chefs über Nacht zu irgendwelchen Umweltengeln geworden sind, die gesagt haben, äh, ah, ja, äh, meine Kinder haben mich dazu überredet, ich werde jetzt Umweltschützer.
Das ist auch Schwachsinn.
Denen ist aufgefallen, der Scheiß verkauft sich besser, wenn man es grün macht.
Oder wenn man so tut, als ob es grün ist.
Das ist denen doch nicht über Nacht eingefallen.
Die haben festgestellt, wenn man grün draufschreibt, dann verkauft sich das besser.
Genauso wie irgendwie ein Hersteller, der Dinger in China oder was weiß ich, Nordkorea oder in Bangladesch mit Kinderarbeit produzieren lässt, der ist auch nicht über Nacht geläutert und sagt, ach nee, das war doch so eine schlechte Idee, wir geben denen jetzt mehr Geld.
Nee, das machen die nur, weil es schlecht ankommt.
Das ist einfach, das geht überhaupt nicht darum, dass die irgendwie jetzt was für den Umweltschutz oder sonst was machen wollen.
Das ist denen vollkommen egal.
Die stellen das jetzt einfach so hin.
Wenn ich mir angucke auf Twitter, teilweise Werbung von Shell und Konsorten, so nach dem Motto, wie viele Bäume sie jetzt gepflanzt haben und sowas, wo ich mir immer denke, was zum Teufel, warum habt ihr auf einmal so euren grünen Daumen entdeckt?
Na gut, klar, weil es gut ankommt, ja, weil es gut ankommt.
Und wir werden sehen und sehen das ja auch schon, dass im Zuge von Klimawandel und Maßnahmen einfach ganz viel...
...Klimawandel und Maßnahmen einfach ganz viel...
...viele Leute sich versuchen, da dran zu bereichern.
Also man sollte nicht alles blind durchwinken und sagen, ja, ja, ist schon gut fürs Klima, man muss das wirklich hinterfragen.
So nach dem Motto, ist das wirklich sinnvoll oder will da einfach nur einer schnelle Kohle machen?
Und wahrscheinlich kannst du dir im überwiegenden Teil der Fälle das damit beantworten, dass einfach nur jemand Kohle machen will.
Naja, gibt's an vielen Ecken.
So, also, was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Okay, alles klar.
Also, ähm, doch, ich find...
...ich bin ja auch skeptisch gewesen lange Zeit, ob Elektroautos sowas Sinnvolles sind.
Ich find Elektroautos sinnvoll, wobei man halt sagen muss, es ist sicherlich, und das ist, das ist wie bei vielen, es ist sicherlich nicht das Allheilmittel.
So nach dem Motto, äh, wir haben jetzt Elektroautos und es gibt keine Umweltprobleme mehr.
Die Hauptfrage bei Elektroautos ist ja nach wie vor, wie werden die, also, wie werden die Autos hergestellt und vor allem, wie wird der Strom hergestellt für die Autos?
Was Elektroautos aber auf jeden Fall bringt, ist weniger Dreck in der Stadt und das finde ich schon mal ganz gut.
Das hab ich gesehen, das ist...
...das ist tatsächlich, tatsächlich interessant, das können wir echt gucken.
Wobei, wobei, das Video fand ich unterm Strich gar nicht so gut.
Die haben schon, die, die, die haben, die haben schon bessere Videos gemacht.
Weil im Intro sagen die, das können wir uns später mal angucken, im Intro sagen die so nach dem Motto, es ist einfacher als man denkt.
Und dann zeigen sie zwölf, äh, zwölf Minuten lang, äh, Dinger, wozu wir wahrscheinlich die nächsten 5000 Jahre, was auch immer, niemals imstande sein werden.
Aber einfacher als man denkt.
Ja.
Und...
...die Sache, die mich auch persönlich nervt, ist, dass wir den zweiten Schritt vor dem ersten erwägen.
Was ich meine, also, was ich damit meine, ist folgendes.
Es gibt Diskussionen, ob man nicht Autos generell oder zumindest Verbrennungsautos, was auch immer, äh, oder, ich sag jetzt einfach mal der Einfachheit halber, Autos in der Innenstadt verbieten soll.
Die Diskussion hab ich ja überhaupt keine Probleme damit.
Aber es ist aktuell einfach noch gar nicht möglich.
Das kannst du machen, wenn du beispielsweise...
...A-Verkehr so weit ausgebaut hast oder zumindest mal bei der Bahn Leute hingesetzt hast, die es persönlich interessiert, dass der Scheiß auch funktioniert.
Wenn du dich darauf verlassen kannst, dass du von A nach B kommst, ohne ein eigenes Auto, wenn es pünktlich sein muss.
Du kommst ja jetzt schon von A nach B, aber du kannst dich halt nicht darauf verlassen, dass es pünktlich ist.
So.
Solange das nicht gegeben ist, wie willst du das machen?
Willst du einfach, dass die Hälfte der Leute morgens nicht mehr auf die Arbeit kommt oder wie?
Wie soll das, wie soll das funktionieren?
So.
Und wenn...
...du das hinbekommen hast...
...dann verzichten garantiert ganz viele Leute auf ihr Auto, die sagen, hey, mir ist es eh lieber, mit öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln zu fahren, wenn es eben eine sinnvolle Alternative ist, als mit dem Auto.
Ich würde das auch lieber machen, sag ich euch.
Ich mach's ja, ich mach's ja schon.
Ich, ich, ich mach's ja schon, ja.
Ähm, aber ich bin auch regelmäßig abgefuckt.
Ihr kennt meine Tweets an die Bahn.
Das geht, ich, ich arbeite in Frankfurt und das geht nicht.
Du hast oft genug Probleme.
Das geht höchstens, wenn du direkt in Frankfurt wohnst, dass du in eine U-Bahn einsteigen kannst, die alle zwei Minuten fährt.
Das funktioniert.
Wenn du ein bisschen von außerhalb...
...kommst, was in Frankfurt der riesige, überwiegende Teil der Leute ist, dann geht das nicht.
Frankfurt ist ja eine Stadt, die hat, was weiß ich, ich sag jetzt mal irgendwas, ich weiß nicht, ob es wirklich stimmt.
Die hat, keine Ahnung, 900.000 Einwohner in der Nacht und 5 Millionen Einwohner am Tag.
Jetzt übertrieben gesagt.
Also, ein Riesenteil der Leute fährt eben von außen nach Frankfurt, beziehungsweise fährt mit der Bahn.
Das funktioniert einfach nicht.
Also, wenn du dich wirklich drauf verlassen musst, dann würde ich auch mit dem Auto fahren, anstatt mit der Bahn.
So, und wenn das so ist, also wenn ich mich da wirklich drauf verlassen könnte, dann hätte ich noch nicht mal mehr ein Auto.
Das ist ja nur notgedrungen für die Fälle, wo ich weiß, ey, ich muss pünktlich sein, aber die Bahn kriegt es nicht gebacken oder ich komme nicht hin.
Das würde ich machen.
Und ich denke, das würden auch noch viel mehr machen.
Warum sollte man es?
Und in der Stadt kommt man mittlerweile auch wunderbar mit Roller und sowas.
Das funktioniert alles.
Aber jetzt schon über den zweiten Schritt vor dem ersten zu reden, Autos zu verbieten, bevor der Nahverkehr richtig funktioniert, halte ich für total kontraproduktiv.
Denn man bringt ja damit auch die Leute auf, gegen eigentlich sinnvoll.
Und das ist ja auch eine der tollen Ideen.
Was hast du für ein Auto?
Ich habe das agilste Auto aller Zeiten, so ein in grün auch noch, so ein, GG Eats, das ist uralt, das ist 20 Jahre alt oder so das Auto, ja, ist ja auch, 2001, also ich habe das keine 20 Jahre, aber das ist 20 Jahre alt, seht ihr mal, ich fahre nicht viel Auto, sonst hätte ich auch schon irgendwas anderes als das Teil.
Richtige Banger-Karre.
Das, guck mal, wenn du das tiefer legen willst, das kannst du nicht mal tiefer legen, wo sollst du das noch hin tiefer legen?
Bei den kleinen Reifen.
Das kannst du nix machen, ja.
Also, ich glaube, ich glaube, okay, es geht immer irgendwie, aber ich glaube, ich habe noch nie einen getunten Opel Agila gesehen, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das funktioniert.
Ich bin aber auch kein Autotuning-Mensch, ja, ich nicht.
Fährt sich sehr agil.
Um ehrlich zu sein, fährt sich das nicht sonderlich agil.
Wenn du, sag mal so,
ab 80 merkst du schon,
dass es, naja, nicht wackelt, aber da merkst du
den Gegenwind schon, dass das
Auto irgendwie
komisch ist, ja.
Sondern du schnell kannst
damit ja auch nicht fahren.
80 fühlt sich an wie 200.
Ja, ist fast so.
Also, wenn du da mit 120 oder so fährst,
du denkst wirklich, dass
du bist in einer Rakete
oder so vom Wackeln her oder
im Flugzeug, was gleich startet.
Guck mal hier,
hat jemand, die Big Brain hat gleich jemand nachgeguckt.
Die hinterkreisen 400.000 Menschen nach Frankfurt
und machen damit die zur Pendlerhauptstadt.
Genau, genau. Und da kannst du nicht einfach sagen,
es gibt keine Autos mehr in Innenstädten.
Jeder, der freiwillig mit dem Auto nach Frankfurt fährt,
der macht das. Okay, nicht jeder.
Sag mal, 95%. Es gibt 5%, die machen das, weil Autofahren geil ist.
Aber die meisten machen das,
weil es sonst keine sinnvolle Alternative für sie gibt.
Und Frankfurt ist schon gut angebunden.
Fragt euch erstmal, wo es anders ist.
Und der Rest macht es wie ich.
Der Autofahrer fährt hauptsächlich mit der Bahn aus.
Pünktlich sein, dann fährt er mit dem Auto.
Deswegen kann man jetzt gar nicht sagen,
nicht jetzt schon, so nach dem Motto,
oh, gibt's nicht mehr.
Du musst erstmal den ersten Schritt vor dem zweiten machen.
Dann machen da auch viele mit.
Sicher.
Übrigens, ich muss euch ein Video zeigen,
das ist mega lustig.
Wir gucken uns erstmal
den, Moment,
wo ist der Lockpicking-Läuer?
Hier.
Wir gucken uns erstmal den Lockpicking-Läuer
und danach gucken wir uns das Verarschungsvideo.
Das ist so gut gemacht.
Den kennen wir ja.
Den gucken wir ja öfters.
Wir wissen jetzt schon, was passiert.
Er nimmt seinen Dietrich,
macht dreimal hin und her
und das Ding ist auf.
Amazon.
Jeff freut sich.
Eine Smartphone-App.
Okay, das ist, Leute,
ihr wisst, ich hab
Smart-Home-technisch
vieles am Start und bin da auch immer am Basteln.
Aber Smart-Logs
kommen mir nicht in die Tür, nicht ins Fenster,
nicht ins Auto, nirgendwo hin.
Smart-Logs, das seh ich nicht ein.
Das Ding hat, es gibt die letzten Jahre
über so viele Sicherheitsprobleme.
Mein Lieblings-Feature,
war ja immer noch die Möglichkeit,
Leute einzuladen, wenn man nicht daheim ist.
Gab's ja bei einem Smart-Log.
Da konntest du Leute einladen,
wenn man nicht daheim ist.
Das Problem war bloß, der Invite-Link,
der war so easy, selbst zu generieren,
dass man sich quasi selbst
inviten konnte.
Man musste, glaube ich,
man konnte sich selbst inviten,
weil der Invite-Link total einfach zu generieren war.
Das heißt, man konnte in fremde Häuser rein damit.
...
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Easy.
Ah, Klick, Klick auf One.
Two is Binding.
Ah, ne, doch nicht.
die sie einfach wackelt schämt machen das immer das gleiche das ist schon zwei
jahre her da müsste man musste mal suchen wir können auch gleich danach
suchen du konntest über die app in weiß verschicken und es war möglich dass du
quasi obwohl du nicht in weitet wurde es dir den wahrscheinlich war es immer der
gleiche link oder so was wahrscheinlich musstest du die id wahrscheinlich
musstest du müssen wir müssen gleich mal so wahrscheinlich musstest du die
id wissen und das war dann wahrscheinlich einfach nur den link
mit einer id und einem usernamen oder was auch immer
lohan security are starting to become a lock set klischee as such consumers
really need to know what they're buying especially when dealing with an unknown
brand in any case that's all i have for you today if you do have any questions
or comments about this please put them below if you like this video and would
like to see more like it please subscribe and as always
have a nice day thank you
gucken wir gucken wir uns gleich gucken wir uns gleich an aber jetzt habt ihr
den original lockpicking leuer gesehen ihr müsst euch mal die parodie angucken
ich habe mich übelst wecke weggekackt dabei als das gesehen habe das jetzt
fähig da hat die sprechweise auch übelst geil drauf
da hat das auch noch übelst gut drauf wie der redet das ist fast wie das originale
this is the lockpicking lawyer and today i have a very special video for you
usually a puzzle is sent for me to solve but today i've been put in a puzzle
against my own will i've been informed by a silly looking puppet on a television
that to sleep a sacrifice is required and here are the rules there is an explosive
next to my arm on a timer that will make sure my lockpicking days are
over if i don't get out in time to escape however i need to push down with
my hand which will crush the perfectly good condition and innocent abuse padlock
as a sacrifice that is not going to happen so we have to escape lockpicking
lawyer style i very quickly noticed that this trap is filled with very serious
security flaws one of them is the fact in my left arm is not completely tied
down and the other is this
an incredibly cheap chinese padlock i could probably get this open just by
thinking about it hard enough but we are going to humiliate the trap designer and
we will pick it open i picked up this paper clip from the ground and bent it
wisst ihr was das schlimme ist der originale lockpick der könnte es wirklich
damit öffnen wahrscheinlich so let's dive right in unfortunately i do not have a
tension wrench so i have to use my thumbnail as a tension wrench okay we got one binding
two is set same on three clicker four das ist wie das original same on five okay back
to the beginning one is reset two is set and there we go we have the trap open es ist die
beste parodie die ich in der richtung hier gesehen habe das ist so nah am original dran
und auch die sprüche
and just like that
in about 30 seconds the trap is completely non-functional and now it's just a matter
of getting the leather strap out let's make sure the device is safe and we are done okay
folks as you can see this device offers vanishingly little security when it comes to keeping the
victims in it this device i would not recommend if you're looking for near-death experiences
in any case
so that's all i have for you today if you have any questions or comments about this
please put them below if you like this video and would like to see more liking please
subscribe and as always have a nice day thank you ich habe ja gedacht am ende passiert
noch was ich dachte das ich dachte eigentlich das explodiert jetzt noch oder irgendwas
aber nee aber es war echt wirklich müsst ihr mal zugeben nah am original dran oder
well the device that i purchased on amazon for about 125.000 euro das ist wirklich ein
scherz das ist ein scherz das ist ein scherz das ist ein scherz das ist ein scherz das ist
ein scherz das ist ein scherz das ist ein scherz das ist ein scherz das ist ein scherz das ist ein scherz
das ist so das echt gut gemacht also gucken wir mal kurz was was hier smartlog ich glaube
heiser hat dazu damals was geschrieben ist schon ein bisschen her einladungen die gehen
ja hier schon smart home plus schlösser passwörter im klartext fängt ja schon mal gut an aber
das meine ich nicht tja na was suche ich denn jetzt dass ich das noch finde smartlog einladung
exploit
gestern weit
es ist es ist auf jeden fall von arsch also es gibt hier ist im prinzip kann
es in der suche da was willst ich würde nie in den smartphone ich finde das
andere jetzt nicht
ja das april chance video kenne ich
und das ist der grund warum ich mir nie
smartlocks irgendwie einbauen würde
ich sehe es überhaupt nicht ein
dass leute sich irgendwie
per app selbst in beiden können oder sonstwas klar und auch wenn es letzten
jahre über besser geworden ist
also gegen so ein schlüssel
gab ich sie weiß ich also schlüssel ist mir lieber
zumal
eines der bedenken die ich ja immer ab was smart home sachen angeht und und
und smartphone
solange ich nicht weiß wie die funktionieren
betraut der sache auch nicht dass sie sicher ist
zumindest
solange man nicht so grob nachvollziehen kann wie sie funktionieren
es sagen alle hersteller immer sie sind super sicher und sagen alle hersteller
immer
experten haben das kontrolliert und konnten keine probleme finden und da
bla bla
guckt euch mal wie oft wurden irgendwelche park irgendwelche passwort
cloud passwort manager schon
daten abgegriffen oder
bei bei den weiß camps letztens
die geschichte mit das über den
china chinesen server alle video feeds und sowas zugänglich war das ist halt
lächerlich irgendwie die sagen natürlich ich würde es an der stelle stelle von
dem hersteller auch behaupten
das alles super sicher ist und
es war keine probleme geben kann und was auch immer
bei autoschlüsseln gibt ja noch was anderes
bei autoschlüsseln da habe ich auch in kohlen angriff gelesen von der zeit
es gibt ja autos dies die die locken sich selbst
der schlüssel hat in den sender keine ahnung oder in dem wegen bluetooth zeug
oder wie auch immer das ist
und wenn du dich vom auto entfernt
dann lockt sich das auto selbst eigentlich eine coole idee aber da habe
ich letztens
gesehen dass du beispielsweise das signal verlängern kannst also du zum
beispiel du guckst irgendeinem typ zu und dann wartest an der seite vom
parkplatz dann der typ steigt aus dem auto oder die
steigt aus dem auto also die die auto fahrer innen steigen aus dem auto und
dann hast du irgendein gerät was das signal vom schlüssel zum auto quasi
weiterleitet also normalerweise sollte sich das automatisch locken das auto
nach wenn er wenn er irgendwie zwei meter weg ist aber du leitest das signal
vom Schlüssel weiter an das Auto, du verstärkst das, du leitest das weiter, du repeatest das irgendwie und dann ist der 15 Meter vom Auto weg und das Auto ist immer noch nicht gelockt, sieht das aber nicht und du kannst ins Auto rein, da gab es auch schon genug Angriffe in dieser Richtung,
also das ist ja unsicher, zumal das Fatale an diesen, wir leiten die Signale weiter, Security-Probleme ist, du musst ja noch nicht mal die Verschlüsselung irgendwie knacken zwischen Auto und Schlüssel oder was es da für Security-Geschichten gibt, du musst einfach das Layer-1-Signal weiterleiten,
also du musst einfach nur das, was da an, weiß nicht was es ist, Bluetooth oder irgendwelche Funkdinger geschickt wird, musst du einfach,
nur weiterleiten, was auch lustig ist, ist Smart-Logs mit Alexa, da gab es ja auch schon genug Fälle, wo die Leute ein Fenster auf hatten und jemand gesagt hat, ich spreche jetzt das Wort nicht aus, so ein, ja ihr wisst schon, Tür öffnen und dann hat der Lautsprecher gesagt, ja Fronttür wird geöffnet,
tja und er hat halt das Fenster aufgehabt und dann haben die Leute die Tür aufgeschlossen, das, ach das ist diese, du hast 150 Punkte oder so ausgegeben und das Emote zu, das wusste ich gar nicht, dass das mittlerweile drin ist,
dass du, ich kenne bloß die Sonnenbrille, genau, das gibt es auch noch, das gibt es auch noch, dass die, dass die Autos sich entlocken, wenn du in die Nähe kommst, aber wie gesagt, der Angriff, wo ich drüber gelesen habe, ist nur, dass sie das Signal weiter verlängert haben, so als wäre der Typ noch neben dem Auto und obwohl er eigentlich gar nicht mal neben dem Auto war, ja genau, ja, wundert mich nicht, ja, wie gesagt, das ist alles, alles im Bereich des Möglichen, deswegen habe ich meine Vorbehalte gegenüber Smart-Logs,
weil, sagen wir mal so, einen Raspberry Pi sich runterladen, äh, Schwachsinn, einen Raspberry Pi und sich die passende Software dafür runterladen kann, mehr oder weniger jeder, einen Log-Picking-Lawyer-Style-Schloss knacken kann nicht jeder, ich würde zumindest sagen, die Einstiegshürde ist höher,
Dankeschön, Groove Electric, sechs, äh, acht Monate Subscription, nö, wenn es eine ordentliche Stimmerkennung gäbe, dann könnte ich jetzt auch nicht Alexa sagen und bei euch gehen die Lautsprecher an, wenn ihr einen habt und mich auf laut habt, nö,
das ist kein Ding, das funktioniert, hm, man kann sicherlich vieles machen, aber in dem Fall, wo das funktioniert hat, hat man das nicht gemacht, es ist ja immer so ein Wettlauf zwischen dem, was Hackermans machen und zwischen dem, was Hersteller machen,
wisst ihr, was ich ein, ein, äh, was ich dumm finde, in welchem Bereich die Hersteller gerade versus die Hackermans gewinnen, das ist Twitch und YouTube-Werbung, ist jetzt vielleicht ein doofer Vergleich, aber Twitch und YouTube-Werbung kann man schlecht unterdrücken,
sowohl im browser als auch mobile oder immer schwerer was natürlich nicht heißt dass ihr
twitch werbeblocke anmachen sollten weil ich muss ich muss ja was verdienen oder er macht
werbeblocke an und gibt mir den prime sagt das ist natürlich die pfeife der pfeiffert move md
dankeschön brenn subskript massive subs hier wieder gut leute also gucken wir mal ein bisschen
was was haben wir denn hier hätte sie vielleicht keine battlefield flank battlefield 20 42 das
remake das immer wird mal gucken wer das video spricht da platz war ich von der games da immer
abhängig wer das wäre wer das video spricht ob ich mir das angucke oder nicht maurice beste
den haben wir hier endlich ist der robo hund aus dem saal dimitri der ist auch gut den kann man
sich auch angucken des portals peter an das news portals okay das kann man so wie tron stellt
mit dem mit riege kombi sagt der geheime riesige neuen modus von battlefield 20 ja gut das haben
wir zusammen geguckt er heißt portal des wasser man das macht warum entwend man worte song moment
das muss jetzt das wird auch nicht gestreikt das ist auch nicht toll aber das ist hier huge
eines wo ich immer noch immer noch eines der besten game soundtracks überhaupt
ich sage euch wenn man schlecht drauf ist also wenn ihr mal richtig schlecht
gelaunt seid hört euch die beiden portal songs an
we can und so hat er danach seine gleich viel besser drauf
kill me
du stehst bester bester game song
ja die die die klar aus sprecherin hat es auch live gesungen schon mehrfach
naja
special thanks to elin verdell alles klar
corona obwohl ich habe ich habe jetzt meine erste impfung jetzt kriege ich das
ja schwerer bist du mit deinem aktuellen job
zufrieden
jo
ein bisschen mehr geld könnte sein aber ansonsten will ich mit mehr geld geht
immer mehr geld geht immer aber ja für mich nicht schlecht was ich aktuell
macht
max hast du das team deck schon bestätigt warum ich sehe erst mal für
mich keinen mehrwert für das team deck
auch der name macht mich immer noch fertig die nähe von steam deck zu stream
deck finde ich unglücklich welchen converter laptop keine ahnung geräte kann er konsumieren
Geräte-Klasse, die mich nicht interessiert.
Jetzt hört auf mich immer
zu auszulösen mit solchen Fragen.
Löst mich nicht so sehr aus.
Die kriegen das, die
dritte Teile kriegt Valve nicht hin, das wissen
wir doch. Wie findest du Safari?
Schlecht.
Safari ist der neue Internet-Explorer
unter den Browsern.
Und es bleibt einem unter iOS leider nichts anderes
übrig, als Safari zu verwenden.
Es gibt ja keine anderen Browser für iOS.
Das ist die, damit
mit dieser Antwort löse ich den Chat immer aus.
Da triggere ich immer richtig den Chat.
Ich weiß genau, dass ich damit den Chat
triggere.
Aber das Schöne ist,
nachdem ich das erzählt habe, kann ich dann auch
gleich den Leuten erzählen, die sagen, stimmt nicht,
dass sie Unrecht haben. Das ist nämlich
immer das Beste. Am besten ist, man triggert
die Leute und wenn dann die Antwort
kommt, die man ja schon erwartet hat, dann
kann man ihnen sagen, ihr habt nicht recht. Und zwar, ihr habt
nicht recht, es gibt auf iOS
nur Safari. Ihr könnt zwar
Chrome und Firefox runterladen,
aber das bleibt
weiterhin in Safari.
Das Einzige, was Chrome
und Firefox unter iOS machen, ist ein Custom
GUI. Die Browser Engine,
das Rendering, das JavaScript,
alles mögliche, ist Safari.
Also es gibt unter iOS keinen
anderen Browser als Safari.
Pech. Ist halt so.
Apple schreibt das ja sogar offiziell.
Apple schreibt ja
sogar, du darfst, also wenn du
die Sachen über den App Store vertreiben willst,
du darfst keine andere Browser
Engine bundeln oder verwenden als
das mit den mitgelieferten Safari Webview.
Ja, ist so.
Ist so.
Ja, ja, echt jetzt.
Echt jetzt.
Habt ihr euch nicht schon mal gefragt, warum Safari
beziehungsweise Chrome und Firefox
unter iOS so kacke sind im
Vergleich zu Desktop und Android?
Na klar, weil es immer Safari ist.
Das Problem an Safari ist,
dass die mittlerweile, wie gesagt,
Safari ist der neue Internet Explorer.
Guckt euch mal beispielsweise die
PWA-Unterstützung von Safari an
oder guckt euch Notifications,
Web-Notifications an
oder, keine Ahnung, es gibt Seiten, da kannst du
schön vergleichen nebeneinander. Safari kann
fast nix von modernen Sachen.
Okay, fast nix. Das war jetzt ein bisschen
übertrieben. Im Vergleich zu anderen
Browsern kann Safari deutlich weniger.
Und das ist nervig.
Ja, wisst ihr?
Wie findest du All Projects? Hab ich mal
ganz am Anfang ausprobiert. Ich hab nicht den
Mehrwert erkannt und hab's wieder gelöscht.
Ähm, das hatten wir, glaube ich, schon mal
in nem Video. IT-Mythen-Video.
Das neue Proton
will Windows endlich überflüssig machen? Ne.
Wird es nicht.
Es wird's vielleicht besser machen,
dass auch mehr Sachen unter Linux laufen
beziehungsweise hauptsächlich dann wahrscheinlich erstmal
unter SteamOS. Muss man mal gucken, wie
einfach man das neue Proton auf anderen Plattformen
zum Laufen bekommt. Aber überflüssig wird's
das garantiert nicht machen. Es sind ja
nicht nur Spiele. Es sind ja nicht nur Spiele.
Es gibt ja auch Software, ne? Manche Leute
verwenden Sony Vegas oder irgendwie
Adobe Premiere oder oder was weiß ich
von Photoshop bis sonst was. Klar, es gibt
die ein oder andere Alternative unter Linux
unter Mac E. Äh,
ja genau, unter Mac sowieso.
Aber vieles kannst du halt einfach nicht
ersetzen. Vor allem, wenn du deinen gewohnten Workflow
beibehalten willst. Und da wird dir Proton auch nicht
jetzt so viel dabei helfen.
Also die Mischung aus
DX, wie heißt das Ding? DXVX?
DAVX?
Proton und Wine?
Das wird die letzten, die nächsten
Jahre immer mehr dafür sorgen, dass immer mehr
spielen kannst, klar, und immer mehr läuft. Aber
das wird Windows wahrscheinlich auf absehbare
Zeit nie überflüssig machen.
Allein schon Gaming-Browser, was auch immer das
sein soll, ja.
Was muss deine meiner
Mozilla machen, um wieder erfolgreich
mit Firefox zu sein?
Firefox ist ja nicht schlecht. Oder Firefox war ja nie
schlecht. Was mich abfuckt an Firefox
ist, dass die
immer mehr auf Tablet-App machen.
Auf dem Desktop. Na, das fängt
an mit solchen komischen Menüs. Die lassen
sich dermaßen beschissen bedienen,
also Firefox sollte mal wieder, wie sagt
man so schön?
Umarmen die eigentliche
Zielgruppe und das in meiner Meinung nach
technisch interessierte User, die
die Addon-Vielfalt zu schätzen wussten,
die Developer-Tools immer noch zu schätzen
wissen, die aber ihren Desktop auf dem
Browser auch wie eine Desktop-Anwendung
bedienen wollen und nicht mit diesem ganzen
Kack, den sie teilweise haben.
Das muss Firefox machen.
Cryolite Gaming, danke schön für den Prime-Sub.
Ja auf dem Desktop halt nicht
Trotz Kappa
Auf dem Desktop halt nicht
Edge, kann man verwenden
Aber wozu
Ich verstehe immer noch die Daseinsberechtigung
Von Edge nicht so ganz
Ja ist ja gut, muss sich jeder selbst überlegen was er haben will
Also wenn einer sagt er ist
Zufrieden, das was läuft
Auf Steam Deck und er findet das Gerät gut
Und er möchte schon, wollte schon immer mal gerne
Keine Ahnung, alte RPGs
Oder ältere Games oder was auch immer
Irgendwas was gut läuft
Mobil spielen, ist das eine super Geschichte, klar, keine Frage
Neue Spiele mobil wird eh schwierig
Selbst wenn du Windows installierst, weil der Akku wahrscheinlich einfach nicht lang hält
Also du wirst auf dem Steam Deck
Garantiert, selbst wenn du Windows installierst
Du wirst auf dem Steam Deck garantiert kein
Was weiß ich, was kommt denn da draus
Keine Ahnung
Kein Battlefield 20, 42
5 Stunden spielen, vergess mobil
Wenn du da auf 2 bis 3 Stunden
Wenn es hoch kommt
2 bis 3 Stunden kommst, ist schon
Viel
Also du kannst damit noch nicht mal eine etwas längere
Zugfahrt irgendwas spielen
Multiplayer wird eh nichts
Eh nix werden
Ach stimmt, das neue Battlefield hat ja gar kein Singleplayer
Ich vergaß
Dann nicht, dann denkt euch was anderes aus
Ja ich stelle mir übrigens
Steam Deck auch richtig cool vor, wenn du was emulieren willst
Was richtig nice wäre
Wenn es bis dahin ordentliche
Switch Emulatoren gibt
Ich weiß, dass es welche gibt, aber ich rede von ordentlichen
Da wo du zum Beispiel auch Mario Odyssey oder sowas drauf spielst
Dann
Das wäre das nice
Da kannst du nämlich auf dem Steam Deck Switch Spiele spielen
Besser als auf der Switch
Was ist der beste N64 Emulator?
Keine Ahnung, ich habe lange kein N64 mehr emuliert
Und wie willst du die ROMs herbekommen?
ROMs zieht man natürlich immer vom
Original Datenträger, den man selbstverständlich besitzt
Na was denn sonst?
Ich hoffe ihr macht nix anderes
Sag ich doch
So was schauen wir uns jetzt als nächstes an
Zeig mal her
Ich glaube, dass wir jetzt mal
Blank
Okay, genau, das Gamestar Video wollen wir uns angucken
Portal
This was a triumph
Ach stimmt, ja, deswegen bin ich auf die Portal-Song gekommen
Okay, nicht das Portal
Aber Battlefield Portal hat mit dem klassischen Portal
Ich finde den Namen tatsächlich ganz gut
Das habe ich auch gesagt, als wir uns das zusammen angucken haben
Ich finde den Namen Battlefield Portal ganz gut
Das passt ganz gut
Man hätte es deutlich schlechter treffen können
Und es ist nicht der Kuchen
Weil die Geheimhaltung von da ist nämlich genauso gut für uns
Und es funktioniert wie das Vertuschen der Watergate Affäre
Gab es im Vorfeld haufenweise Leaks zu Battlefield Portal
Das ist Absicht
Und was soll ich sagen, die stimmen
Battlefield Portal
Beste hier, beste
Ähm, tja
Wie gesagt, ich habe das ja auch schon gesehen
Zwei Tage oder irgendwie so
Bevor das angekündigt wurde, Battlefield Portal
Wir hatten danach noch eine Frage-und-Antwort-Session
Wo immer wieder die gleichen Sachen gefragt wurden
Die nicht beantwortet wurden
Ähm
Zum Beispiel, dass wir uns nicht mehr so gut fühlen als wir es gemacht haben
Ähm, zum Beispiel, dass wir uns nicht mehr so gut fühlen als wir es gemacht haben
Zum Beispiel, Skill-Based Matchmaking, Battle Royale
Was auch immer, dazu sagen sie ja nichts großartig
Die haben eh nur die Fragen rausgepickt
Die ihnen gut gefallen
Martin, Dankeschön für die 24 Monate Subscription
Das ist ja doppelte Hyper-Subscription hier schon
Fuck
Danke für die ganzen Subs
Ähm
Ja, und da wurde am Prinzip auch nichts großartiges beantwortet
Außer die Fragen, die ihnen gut gefallen haben
Kann man machen, wenn man es nicht mehr so gut fühlt
Sie veranstalten das Event, ja
Luis, ich würde nichts darauf geben, was irgendjemand irgendwo jetzt erzählt
Sondern erstmal, wenn das Game raus ist
Ich persönlich wäre immer noch skeptisch, wenn gar kein Battle Royale geplant wird
Sie sagen, dass es kein Battle Royale geben wird
Aber die drücken das immer so um die Ecke aus
So nach dem Motto
In den bisher vorgestellten Spielmodi wird kein Battle Royale vorhanden sein
Und sowas
Ich fände es immer noch sehr merkwürdig
Wenn die es nicht versuchen würden
Es muss ja nicht so sein, dass es so viel Spielmodi gibt
Es muss ja nicht mal ein klassischer Battle Royale sein, wie man das jetzt kennt
Vielleicht auch einen deutlich Battlefieldigeren Battle Royale
Was auch immer
Irgendwas in der Richtung
Um Warzone zu kontern
Werden die machen
Portal wird
Und sowas gibt es ja auch in Portal 2
Ein riesiger Editor
Mit dem ihr eure eigenen Traum-Matches aus Battlefield 1942
Bad Company 2
Und Battlefield 3 zusammenbasteln könnt
Alles mit neuer Grafik
Neuen Effekten
Neuen Möglichkeiten
Und ich weiß, was manche von euch noch nicht wissen wird
Ich weiß, was manche von euch noch nicht wissen wird
Ich mach mal ein Stückchen zurück. Wobei ich halt sagen muss, die Leute, die das hier anspricht, vermute ich einfach mal, sind auch Leute, die sich fürs Programmieren interessieren. Ich glaube, so der normale, ich weiß nicht, wie groß so die Menge ist der Leute, die sich dafür interessieren, aber nicht fürs Programmieren und dann darin quasi richtig gut werden.
Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen. Also es sieht erstmal ein bisschen mehr so accessible aus, also mehr zugänglich aus, aber ich glaube gar nicht, dass das so wirklich der Fall ist.
Ey, ja, Lua, fang Erased bei 1 an. Weiß auch nicht, was sie sich dabei gedacht haben.
Naja, zumindest ist es cool, dass es das gibt. Ich hab's ja bei der Vorstellung falsch verstanden. Ich dachte ja, es ist ein Level-Editor.
Ich dachte, es ist ein Level-Editor. In Wirklichkeit ist es ja eigentlich nur ein...
Gameplay... Game-Mode-Editor.
Ja, aber mehr Timor, du wirst wahrscheinlich, wenn du das eine Weile benutzt hast, wirst du feststellen, okay, dich interessiert diese Sache aus Logik und Sachen entwerfen und du wirst dich über kurz und lang, wenn dir das gefällt, auch für Programmieren interessieren.
Also gehe ich mal zumindest von aus. Also ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute es da gibt, aber die haben sich sicherlich was beigedacht.
Ich fände es ja cool.
Ich fände es cool, wenn es ein richtiger Level-Editor gewesen wäre. Da ist es leider nicht.
Ich hab nicht richtig zugehört. Ich hab nämlich versucht, als diese Vorstellung war, hab ich versucht, mir einen New-World-Account-Namen zu reservieren, weil die Beta gestartet ist.
Während das Battlefield-Event lief, hab ich nebenbei auf dem zweiten Bildschirm laufen gehabt und ich hab nur nebenbei geguckt und hab gedacht, das wäre ein Level-Editor, aber es ist nur ein Logik-Editor.
... das hier keinen Bock hat. Hat jemand überhaupt sowas wie Doom-Snapmap je benutzt? Gen...
Ein hypothetischer, merkwürdig wütender Battlefield-Fan, denn Battlefield-Portal ist tatsächlich mehr als nur ein Editor. In dem Ding stecken Stärken...
Nein, zu Servern haben sie auch noch nicht wirklich viel gesagt. Das sind Sachen, die immer gefragt werden. Battle Royale, Server und Skill-Based-Matchmaking.
Server und Skill-Based-Matchmaking geht ja so ein bisschen Hand in Hand. Dazu äußern die sich nicht wirklich aussagekräftig.
Das haben die in der letzten FAQ-Session nicht gemacht und das haben die vor ein paar Tagen in der FAQ-Session nicht gemacht.
Echt spannend.
Echt spannend, wenn ihr einfach nur zocken wollt. Also schauen wir uns die Sache mal im Detail an.
Erstmal die Rahmenfakten. Da ist bewirbt aktuell ja wieder und wieder, dass Battlefield 2042 aus drei großen Bereichen bestehen wird.
All-Out-Warfare ist der erste, da habt ihr dann eure regulären Conquest und...
All-Out-Warfare ist eigentlich Battlefield 2042.
... Erfahrungen mit den riesigen neuen Maps, dem neuen Szenario und, und, und. Haben wir euch ja schon im ersten Video vorgestellt.
Genau, das ist das eigentliche neue Battlefield.
Der zweite Bereich heißt Hazard Zone und hier wissen wir...
Competitive.
Nicht, was drinsteht.
Hazard Zone wird, soweit ich das bisher einschätzen kann, alles was wir gesehen haben, wird ein Squad-based Competitive-Versuch von DICE, in was in der Richtung zu machen.
Wie soll etwas wie Portal denn ohne Server vernünftig funktionieren?
Naja, in Overwatch gibt es ja sowas in der Light-Variante auch.
Natürlich gibt es Server, aber keine von dir.
Oder geschweige denn welche, wo du Einfluss hast, wo du drauf kommst.
In Overwatch gibt es ja sowas auch.
Ja gut.
Das stimmt nicht ganz. In Overwatch kannst du Lobbys erstellen und sowas dann und mit den Leuten zusammenspielen.
Das ist kein Ding. Unterm Strich ist das irgendwelche Settings-Dateien, die du wahrscheinlich auf jeden x-beliebigen Battlefield-Server laufen lassen kannst.
Das müssen nicht zwangsläufig von dir gemietete Servers sein.
Also, technisch ist das möglich. Mal gucken, wie die das machen.
Kann ja sein, dass es Lobbys gibt.
Kann auch sein, dass es Lobbys gibt.
Du wählst einfach aus einer langen Liste.
Die Konfig aus, die du haben willst, dann machst du damit eine Lobby auf und wenn du, keine Ahnung, mit zwölf Leuten dann drinnen bist und das Spiel startest, dann wird halt dort irgendwo für dich in irgendeinem Rechenzentrum, auf irgendeiner Hardware, die DICE bezahlt, deine Instanz gestartet mit der Konfig.
Und dann kannst du da drauf spielen.
Das sagt nichts aus über Server-Mieten oder Skill-Based-Matchmaking im normalen Modus.
Nun der frisch enthüllte Battlefield 2042-Portal-Bereich.
Ein Spielplatz, auf dem die Community ihre wildesten Fantasien ausleben kann.
Zum Beispiel ein Team aus modernen Soldaten, die nur mit dem Defibrillator gegen eine Horde von Weltkriegs-Messerkämpfern antreten.
Aber wie funktioniert das im Detail?
Also, Battlefield Portal zieht seine Ressourcen aus den vier beliebtesten Battlefields.
Dem ganz alten Battlefield 1942.
Außerdem Battlefield Bad Company 2.
Dem aktuellen Battlefield 2042.
Und Battlefield 3.
Null Cheatbaited.
Das war so ein schlechter Cheatbait, den hat man meilenweit kommen sehen, Alter.
Aus diesen vier Battlefields stehen euch diverse Karten, Waffen und Fraktionen zur Verfügung, um die wildesten Matchups zu erledigen.
Ich glaube, das steht und fällt damit, ob da neuer Content für kommt, ob die den Content irgendwie monetarisieren können, weil...
Die müssen...
Also, die wollen garantiert langfristig damit irgendwie die, wie soll man sagen, so die langfristige Motivation und die langfristige Monetarisierung sichern.
So nach dem Motto, okay, die Leute sind nicht zufrieden oder denen reicht unser Content nicht, die können sich selbst was machen.
Und die hoffen, dass es vielleicht ein paar coole Community-Sachen gibt, die langfristig dann auch noch Leute begeistern.
Aber die müssen das irgendwie monetarisieren können, aus ihrer Sicht.
Und da bin ich mal gespannt.
DICE nimmt aber nicht einfach die mittlerweile angestaubten Assets von damals.
Sondern rekonstruiert aus alten Maps und Assets in der Engine von Battlefield 2042 alles nochmal neu.
Und das ist in meinen Augen das Beste am ganzen Modus.
Ihr könnt auch einfach die alten Maps und Modi in aktueller Grafik zocken, ganz ohne den Editor.
DICE wird nämlich eine kuratierte Playlist raushauen, in der ich zum Beispiel Conquest of El Alamein spiele.
Oder eine sexy 4K-Variante von Caspian Border aus Battlefield 3.
Stell ich das am besten einfach...
24-7 Metro, easy.
Easy.
Ich bin übrigens nicht dabei, aber Nosha ist dabei.
Das heißt, was es definitiv, das sag ich euch jetzt schon so sicher, wie das Amen in der Kirche geben wird, ist...
In Battlefield 2042, Nosha TDM 24-7.
100 Pro.
Also sofern es eigene Server gibt.
24-7 Nosha TDM.
Und du wirst dort auf dem Server die gleichen Leute sehen, die bisher die letzten 12 Jahre Battlefield 3 TDM...
...Nosha gespielt haben.
...Modus des regulären Multiplayers vor, wenn ihr auf den ganzen Custom-Mode-Booms überhaupt keine Lust habt.
Ich zeige euch jetzt mal alle sechs Oldschool-Maps, die zum Launch verfügbar sein werden.
Allerdings gibt es nicht für alle Karten Gameplay-Footage von der neuen Variante.
DICE hat uns zwar schon gezeigt, wie die neuen Versionen aussehen und ihr seht im Ankündigungs-Trailer auch schon Ausschnitte,
aber wirklich viel ist das noch nicht, also sorry.
Sei es drum, ich bin zwar beileibe kein Experte für gutes Aussehen, aber nehmt mich da trotzdem einfach beim Wort,
die Neuauflagen sehen echt klasse aus.
Mauer-Optik ist bei der Frostbite-Engine ja nie das Problem.
Das stimmt. Sound? Also eine Sache kriegen die bei DICE immerhin. Optik und Sound.
Ne, nein, das ist doch auch sowas, wo sie sich vordrücken, was zu Hardware-Anforderungen zu sagen.
...1942 an. Map Nummer 1 seht ihr hier in der alten Version.
Battle of the Bulge führt euch mitten in die Ardennen-Offensive ins verschneite Westeuropa.
Bulge.
Map Nummer 2 aus Battlefield 1942, El Alamein.
Ein echter Klassiker und klimatisch.
Ein herber Kontrast zur Ardennen-Offensive, denn hier geht's direkt nach Ägypten.
So, kommen wir zu Battlefield Bad Company 2.
Valparaiso.
Hier seht ihr Valparaiso im Original von 2014.
Was hat er denn da in der Mitte?
Das können ja schlechte FPS sein, oder?
...wird wie gesagt Playlists bieten, wo ihr genau das wiedererleben könnt, also klassisch Rush für 24 Spieler.
Alternativ könnt ihr selbst Matches erstellen, wo 128 Leute sich auf der überschaubaren Valparaiso-Map auf die Rübe geben.
Und äh, hänselt mich nicht, wenn ich das falsch ausspreche.
Enemies Around Detektor?
Was soll denn das sein? Das wär ja ein Cheat.
Oder ist das ein Server-Server-Ding?
Und bei der zweiten Map von Bad Company 2 kann ich euch tatsächlich mal den Vergleich zeigen.
Hier im Hintergrund seht ihr das Original-Aerika-Aber von vor elf Jahren.
Auch hier wieder Rush.
Und hier seht ihr die Neuauflage mit einem Custom-Mode namens VIP Fiesta.
Wo die US-Soldaten aus Bad Company 2 gegen US-Soldaten...
Die Beleuchtung ist halt viel besser.
...gegen US-Soldaten.
...von Battlefield 3 antreten, um jeweils einen VIP-Spieler umzunieten.
Die Physik ist halt null Bad Company 2.
Das ist ja auch die Battlefield 2042-Engine.
In Bad Company 2 wäre dieses C4 mit einem Sprung erstmal da hinten auf der Treppe gelandet.
Apropos Battlefield 3.
Auch hier kann ich euch wieder einen Vergleich anbieten.
Hier seht ihr die ursprüngliche Map Caspian Border.
Und ich weiß, da wackeln Battlefield 3-Fans schon jetzt unruhig mit den Beinchen, weil all die Erinnerungen wieder hochkommen.
Und hier der Vergleich.
In dieser Beispielkreation von Battlefield 2042 kämpfen vier moderne...
Ich hab mich gefragt, als wir das geguckt haben, wie oft haben sie diese Szene neu aufgenommen.
Bestimmt 20 Mal, bis der Typ den Headshot gehittet hat.
So nach dem Motto, Alter, mach mal hier Headshot mit deiner silensten G18.
Alter, ich treffe nicht, ich treffe nicht, ich treffe nicht.
Und nach 20 Aufnehmen so Bäm, ja endlich.
...moderne US-Soldaten mit technisch überlegenen Waffen gegen zahlenmäßig überlegene Wehrmachtssoldaten.
Und zu guter Letzt, hier wieder nur mit Originalfootage...
No's here.
...scharer Kanals.
...spielen.
Endlich No's here.
Das waren alle sechs Maps.
Ihr seht hier nochmal in der bildlichen Übersicht alles auf einem...
Stimmt, das ist gescriptet, der hat gar nicht getroffen.
Dazu lassen sich in Battlefield Portal natürlich auch alle Maps des regulären 2042 spielen.
Also beispielsweise Orbital, die seht ihr hier in einem Custom-Mode, in dem ein Panzer gegen 20 fahrende Roboter antritt.
So, ihr habt also alle diese sechs Maps mit den jeweils beteiligten...
Übrigens, eine Sache, die ich überhaupt nicht mag an Battlefield 2042, ist der neue Trailer-Soundtrack.
So diese...
This is war...
Es wäre viel geiler mit Battlefield-Theme, sag ich euch.
Es ist so.
Guck mal, was ist besser?
Pass mal auf.
Jetzt wäre Real Talk.
Battlefield 2042 Trailer.
So, was ist...
Alter, jetzt nerv nicht rum.
Was?
Meine Güte!
So, was ist besser?
Das hier?
Dieses Gedöns da?
Oder?
Was ist besser?
Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Also das ist doch um Längen besser als das andere.
Und das Battlefield 4-Theme ist schon nicht das bessere.
Ist schon nicht das beste.
Ja, es passt null vom Schnitt.
Aber der Typ hat das halt einfach nur hinterlegt.
Aber ich finde vom Sound her ist das viel besser als das originale.
Vor allem jetzt.
Das passt einfach viel besser als das andere.
Gibt's das auch mit Battlefield 2-Theme?
Weil das...
Ja, wollte ich gerade sagen.
Das 1942...
Ich finde, das Battlefield 4 ist halt schon nicht sonderlich gut, ne?
Ne, das ist zu klassisch.
Das passt dazu nicht.
Das ist zu oldschool.
Das ist zu klassisch.
Das bisschen Gestörte von der Musik her fand ich schon ganz gut.
Ja.
Übrigens, doch können sie...
Können sie...
Sie können nicht ständig...
Doch, können sie.
Natürlich können sie das.
Warum?
Warum sollten sie das?
Warum sollten sie das nicht machen?
Ich meine, überlegt...
Guckt mal.
BZ2...
Du kannst ja aus dem Battlefield-Theme einiges rausholen.
Guckt dir mal zum Beispiel die Bad Company 1-Variante davon an.
Die ist komplett anders.
Die ist komplett anders, aber du hörst, dass es das gleiche ist.
Übrigens, ich finde immer noch die beste Battlefield-Variante überhaupt von Bad Company 1.
Das ist das wirklich mega nice.
Da kannst du nix sagen.
Das ist huge pock.
Immer noch unterstützt durch Hetzner, wirklich?
Ups.
Lull.
Hab ich vergessen auszublenden.
Naja.
Aber es ist nice auf jeden Fall.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns schnell das Video fertig an.
Alter, hier ist wieder so brutal warm drinnen.
... im Fall von Battlefield 1942 und so weiter.
Ihr könnt dann, wie gesagt, selbst entscheiden, ob ihr diese alten Maps einfach ganz regulär im altbekannten Modell...
Ist hier so warm drinnen, Alter.
27 Grad.
... das hat dann erstmal mit Custom-Modes...
Official Experiences.
Da konnte das Marketing-Team wieder zuschlagen.
Wobei, das ist relativ Standard mittlerweile.
... falls ihr stattdessen ein Herz für wilde Experimente habt, könnt ihr in den Custom-Modes...
Mich wundert, dass es Official Experience heißt.
Warum heißt es nicht sowas wie All-Time Classics oder All-Time...
... was auch immer irgendwas Cooles.
Official Experiences.
Das ist ja nur wirklich...
... ziemlich...
... äh...
... tja, so...
... so...
... belanglos, ja?
... möglichen Experimente der Community erleben.
Also beispielsweise, wie eben gezeigt, moderne Soldaten gegen die alte Wehrmacht.
Oder die Defibrillator-Armee im Kampf gegen Messerstecher.
Bei diesen Custom-Maps und Modi spielt die Balance übrigens eine sehr untergeordnete Rolle.
Auf der haben Seite...
Nun kommt drauf an, wer den Modus designt.
... über 40 Waffen und über 40 Fahrzeuge der Battlefield-Geschichte in eine große Arena zu werfen, damit ihr möglichst viel Spaß haben könnt.
Aber wer...
... der eine ausbalancierte Erfahrung sucht, sollte bei den offiziellen Modi bleiben.
Als Konsument könnt ihr all das einfach genießen...
Als könnten die das mit dem Ausbalancieren so gut, ne?
... oder es selbst erstellen. Und zwar in eurem ganz stinknormalen Webbrowser.
Ja, das finde ich gut.
Das hat uns auch hier ausgesucht.
Oh, Hackerman.
Erst mal Hollywood aufgemacht, Alter.
Hollywood oder wie heißt das andere?
Oder wie heißt das andere?
... der neue Editor funktioniert.
Wenn es davon kein Material gibt, seht ihr hier im Hintergrund einfach nur so Hacking-Stock-Footage.
Stellt euch das am besten so vor.
Ihr klickt euch im Browser eure gewünschte Einstellung zusammen, also Map, Fraktion, erlaubte Waffen...
Moment, Moment, Moment. Das kann ich besser.
Das kann ich besser.
Das kann ich besser. Sekunde, Sekunde.
Ich muss kurz den Hackerman-Modus starten.
Einfach, einfach, weil es geht.
Der Hackerman-Modus.
Jetzt, jetzt...
Challenge accepted, Alter.
Hackerman-Modus wird...
Hackerman-Modus wird gestartet.
Geht schon mal gut los, ja.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Gleich, gleich kommt der richtige, echte Hackerman-Modus.
Navy CIS-Hacking.
Nee, Navy CIS sind doch die, die alles vergrößern, oder?
Enhanced Zoom.
Hier, bam.
So gehört sich das.
Das ist die einzig wahre Hackerman-Konsole.
Daimona, Chillfreak, danke für den Sub.
Seid ihr schon drin, Chat?
Schon eingeloggt?
Ja, die Cyber-Nuke von Castle, die Szene ist auch nicht schlecht.
Die ist aber so weltfremd schon, dass sie echt lustig ist.
Magentropfen 95.
Ah, nee, Magertropfen 95.
Danke für den Prime-Sub.
So muss das sein.
Das ist mal richtiges Hacker-Footage.
Nächste Mal kann mich die Gamestar gerne als Experten kontaktieren.
Dann nehme ich ihnen ein bisschen Hackerman-Footage auf.
Kein Problem.
Mach ich.
Ich hab meine Konsole kaputt.
Egal.
Die machen weiter.
60k als Deluxe-Admin, 3 Jahre Erfahrung.
Okay, ja.
Kommt ein bisschen aufs Gebiet an, aber klingt prinzipiell erstmal gut.
Oder okay.
Muss es ja auch.
Kannst du wenigstens was Gescheites mitmachen.
By the way, ist euch mal aufgefallen, das habe ich schon ein paar Mal gesehen, als ich diesen Trailer gesehen habe,
das...
Warte mal.
Das ist eine ziemlich komplexe Art.
Dass das da halt so voll nach Gebäude aussieht und dass man nicht rein kann.
So nach dem Motto, man hat einfach ein paar Fenster und Lichter draufgeklebt.
Das sieht nicht aus wie ein Gebäude, was wirklich nach einem Gebäude so aussieht, als wäre es ein Gebäude innen drin.
Eine Angelegenheit.
Und wird wahrscheinlich...
Im Vergleich zu dem Hochhaus oben.
Aber hey, wenn da was Cooles bei rumkommt, warum denn nicht?
Was ich ebenfalls sehr cool finde, ihr könnt auch in Battlefield Portal ganz normal euren Battle Pass hochleveln und Sachen freischalten.
Ja, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, wie sie Cross-Progression machen wollen.
Weil es ist doch total easy, einen Spielmodus zu machen, wo du fucking schnell XP und Waffen-Zeug bekommst.
Das wird garantiert...
Das wird geklitscht des Todes.
In der Trailer zu Battlefield Portal zeigt es ziemlich schön, dass die Levolution-Zerstörung älterer Battlefields in 2042 wieder eine größere Rolle spielen wird.
Und wisst ihr, was im Trailer auch wieder eine größere Rolle spielt?
Dieser dumme Tornado.
Ich sage es hier und jetzt und ihr könnt mich am Ende zur Rechenschaft ziehen, sollte ich mich irren.
Ich bin davon überzeugt, dass dieser Tornado der Spielbalance von Battlefield eher schade als helfen wird.
Klar, das sieht alles cool aus.
Ja, genau das sehe ich auch so.
Man kann das Spiel auch eindrucksvoller bewerben.
Aber ich glaube, dass der Tornado...
Das wird total random und ist einfach nur unsinnig.
Du willst einfach, dass die Map als Struktur eben vorhanden ist und als Map funktioniert.
Ich glaube auch, dass die Wettereffekte aufgesetzte Sachen sind, die man nicht wirklich braucht.
Eines der unbeliebsten Maps bei mir Battlefield 4 war Gull for Forman, das 85. Remake, wegen dem Sandsturm, in dem du nichts gesehen hast.
Und das wird nochmal eine Nummer härter.
...Tornado spätestens beim dritten Mal nervt.
So, habe ich es jetzt gesagt.
Und nun schreibt mir gerne in die Kommentare...
...was ihr über all das denkt, also über Tornados, aber auch über den neuen Battlefield-Portal-Mode.
Habt ihr wie ich in erster Linie Bock auf die alten Karten oder versetzt euch der Editor in Bastellaune?
Ich freue mich über euer Feedback.
Ein Game darf nicht zu chaotisch sein, sonst hast du Call of Duty-Multiplayer...
Ups, äh...
...der dich noob-tubt mit One-Man-Army across the Map...
...und du kannst außer Respawn nichts machen und random getroffen werden.
Das finde ich nicht sinnvoll.
Ich fand Shanghai tatsächlich auch nicht gut, aber nicht wegen der Evolution, sondern weil jedes Mal das Gleiche passiert ist.
Sobald du an den Wolkenkratzer drangekommen bist, bist du da eingestürzt, easy.
Das war einfach langweilig.
Tja, das sind die richtigen Hackerman-Geschichten, ne?
Aber für viele Leute ist das ja schon krasse Hackerman-Geschichte, wenn ich zum Beispiel auf Lieferando gehe.
Pass mal auf.
Jetzt mal mal Hackerman, Hackerman-Extrem.
So.
Hauptbahnhof Frankfurt.
Jetzt kommt Hackerman, passt mal auf.
Viele Leute denken ja schon, das ist was ganz Schlimmes, wobei es absolut nichts macht.
So, wir wollen jetzt hier, ähm...
...mein Chicken haben.
Bam, 10 Euro.
Hinzufügen.
Und jetzt kommt's, Achtung!
Massive.
Massive Hack.
Bam, 99 Cent.
Oh mein Gott!
Solche Hacker-Skills.
Unglaublich.
Moment, das da oben stimmt noch nicht.
Zwischensumme.
Ist doch okay, ist doch okay.
Ist doch, ist doch okay.
Jutsch.
Das, äh, ist für viele schon die, die, die obere Fahnenstange.
Das, ja.
Also, was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Instandsetzung von Vermittlungsstelle und Mobilfunk.
Okay, gucken wir uns eine Runde Telekom-Propaganda an.
Mal gucken, was dabei rauskommt.
Okay, ich bin bei solchen Technik-Videos, da gucke ich immer, was man, was man sieht.
Ich erkenne nix, aber ich kenne mich mit Telekommunikation.
Telekommunikationszeug auch nicht wirklich gut aus, muss ich sagen.
Das sind irgendwelche Sicherungen hier oben, hä?
Sind das Sicherungen?
Das sind wahrscheinlich ganz normale Sicherungen.
So, Clip, Clip, Clip.
Wie, wie nennt man das?
Elektrostell-Leute aus dem Chat.
Ähm, wie, wie, wie nennt man das?
Das ist eine Sicherung.
Wie, wie heißt diese zum Clippen?
Die man, die man so hoch und runter.
Oh.
Sicherungsautomat.
Aha.
Siehste?
Ich wusste doch, dass wir Leute haben, die das wissen.
Huge IQ wieder, Chat.
Alter.
Was ein Hall.
Dem hätten sie mal ein Anclips-Mikro geben sollen.
Guck mal, guck mal.
Das ist der Chef von der, oder das ist, der ist, der ist in Kommunikation, deutsche Telekom-Technik.
Gerade als Kommunikationsmann sollst du wissen, ordentliches Mikrofon, gerade in so nem Ding, wo es halt ist.
Fuck, ist nicht verkehrt.
Aber gut, besser sie fixen die Technik, als dass es gut klingt.
Alter.
Du, du, du hörst, du hörst mehr seine, seine Gummistiefel im Wasser, als die Stimme.
Pumpenstellen.
Jawoll.
Fachinformatiker-Grill.
Ja.
Das wusste ich letztens bei mir im Stall machen.
Das ist eklig.
Und im Stall, das hier ist ja wenigstens noch sauber.
Im Stall sind da noch irgendwelche Tiere drin gewesen.
Und ihr wisst, wie, wie, wie, wie toll ich das finde, wenn da Tiere krabbeln.
Ich muss letztens im Stall auch das Wasser zusammenfegen und mit so ner Pumpe rauspumpen.
Also mit so nem Allzweckpumpen.
Kärcher-Allzweckpumpen-Ding.
Bei einem Stall.
So.
Aber nicht hoch.
Keine Ahnung.
Zehn Zentimeter oder so.
Ausfälle der technischen Infrastruktur bei Hochwasser sind im Prinzip auf...
Okay, was haben wir denn hier?
Auch wieder Sicherungsstelz.
Noch mehr Sicherungsstelz.
Okay, von, von, von IT-Technik.
Was haben wir denn da unten?
Okay, erkennt man jetzt nicht.
Ist das ein QR-Code?
Ich, ich scanne ja manchmal gerne QR-Codes in Videos, um, um zu checken, was es ist.
Aber ich vermute mal, dieser QR-Code ist einfach zu klein.
Den kannst du nicht scannen.
... Probleme zurückzuführen.
Beschädigte oder defekte Kabel, keine Stromzufuhr oder aber wie hier in unserer Vermittlungsstelle
in Untereschbach in der Nähe von Overrath, Technik, die einfach komplett unter Wasser steht.
Sehr deutlich zu sehen an der Marke, die wir auch hier vorne am Technik-Schrank sehen.
Hier stand das Wasser...
Niedereschbach?
Das ist, ähm, hier um die Ecke?
Das ist nicht weit.
Das ist in Frankfurt.
Das ist bei mir um die Ecke.
Wo die, wo die sind.
... sind.
... Gebäude über einen Meter hoch.
Vielen Dank an dieser Stelle an die Feuerwehr, die das Betriebsgebäude leer gepumpt hat, sodass...
Ja, das Hallen ist sehr unangenehm.
Ich weiß, die kriegen es halt nicht gescheit.
Kam dann kein gescheites Mikro.
Ohne Scheiß, da würde ich auch eine Maske aufziehen.
Das ist mir egal, ob es wegen Corona ist, in dem Fall oder sonst was.
Da drinnen stinkt es wahrscheinlich.
Generell, wo Wasser drin ist, da stinkt immer.
Was haben wir da?
Windows.
Ihh, das kann ja nichts werden.
Das geht jedoch nicht immer so einfach.
Haben wir einen QR-Code zum Scannen?
Ja.
Denn wenn die Vermittlungsstelle wieder online ist, heißt das noch nicht, dass die Entstörung schon abgeschlossen ist.
Auch die grauen Kästen, die am Wegesrand stehen, müssen entstört werden oder teilweise sogar instand gesetzt werden,
da sie von den Wassermassen mitgerissen worden sind.
Erst dann können auch die Kundenleitungen wieder online gehen.
Die Deutsche Telekom entstört nach einem Priorisierungsprinzip,
an deren erster Stelle natürlich Polizei, Feuerwehr und alle Hilfsgruppen...
Ja, das ist auch sinnvoll.
... gefolgt von Krankenhäusern, Ärzten oder auch Altenheimen.
Ja, gut, Internet in Altenheimen scheint ja das Allerwichtigste zu sein, ja.
... in solchen Situationen hinzu, dass wir die...
Okay, Telefon, Telefon natürlich, ja.
... rund um eine Störung teilweise gar nicht erreichen können oder aber dürfen, weil noch eine Gefahr besteht oder aber das Gebiet großräumig evakuiert ist.
Telekom verstört.
Da kommt oft die Frage auf, warum ist eigentlich ein Mobilfunkstandort...
Korkas, Bagger.
... während eines Hochfahrts...
Nee, kein Bagger.
Fuck, kein Bagger, das war ein Traktor.
... warum ist eigentlich ein Mobilfunkstandort während eines Hochfahrts beeinträchtigt?
Dies kann mehrere Gründe haben.
Zum einen natürlich die Stromzufuhr.
Auch ein Mobilfunkstandort benötigt Strom.
Und bei einer solchen Extremsituation helfen auch Notstromaggregate nur bedingt.
Ein weiterer wichtiger Faktor ist die Daten...
Ja, Notstromaggregate, gerade wenn es Diesel oder sowas sind, ist bei Überschwemmung äußerst unvorteilhaft.
Also, ab einer gewissen Höhe.
Kannst du es halt vergessen.
... des Mobilfunkstandortes.
Die meisten Standorte der Deutschen Telekom sind per Glasfaser angeschlossen.
Wenn jedoch diese Glasfaseranbindung...
Ja, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Eure Standorte sind per Glasfaser angeschlossen.
Das ist ja schön und gut.
Was ihr aber seit den letzten zehn Jahren nicht nennenswert hinbekommen habt, ist, die Leute mit Glasfaser anzuschließen.
Dass ihr mit Glasfaser angeschlossen seid, ist klar.
Was ist ja auch normal.
... Standort aus.
Hinzu kommt, dass teilweise die...
Dass die ihren Backbau nicht über DSL machen, ist logisch.
... oder über Kupferleitung.
... auch noch kleinere Standorte versorgen, die per Richtfunk angeschlossen sind.
Wenn jedoch der größere Standort ausfällt...
Richtfunk ist kacke.
... für die kleineren Standorte.
Richtfunk ist richtiger Müll.
Vielleicht hatte ich auch einfach noch nie zu tun mit einer ordentlichen Richtfunkanlage, keine Ahnung.
Aber wir hatten früher mal, also beim alten Arbeitgeber,
da hatten wir mal zwischen zwei Gebäuden so eine Mikrowellen-Funkanlage oder so.
Das Ding war so beschissen.
Also, das kann man gar nicht beschreiben.
Das ging einfach zwischendurch nicht.
Also, nicht mal, dass schlechtes Wetter war oder so.
Selbst wirklich strahlend weißer Himmel, alles gut.
Aber da ist wahrscheinlich an der Straße ein LKW vorbeigefahren und hat ein bisschen zu viel gedampft.
Das ist dann zwischen den zwei Gebäuden hochgezogen oder so und dann war die Verbindung weg.
Es war richtig, richtig scheiße, diese Richtfunkgeschichte, die wir da hatten.
Sehr gut. Wie gesagt, es kann auch sein, dass es einfach nur kacke war.
Es war kacke, aber es kann auch sein, dass es einfach nur kacke eingerichtet war.
Weiß ich nicht.
Da hatten wir nichts mit zu tun, wir haben bloß die Auswirkungen von gesehen.
... Wasser hier eine entscheidende Rolle.
Wenn Wasser auf Technik trifft, ist es meistens nicht gut.
So wie auch hier auf unserem dritten Standort in Eustrich.
Die Technik, die vom Wasser beeinträchtigt wurde, muss nun ausgetauscht werden.
Außer, außer Microsoft, die ihre neuen Azure-Rechenzentren im Meer versenken.
... Wasser muss abgepumpt werden und erst dann kann dieser Mobilfunkstandort auch wieder in Betrieb gehen.
Mobilfunk hat für uns momentan die höchste Priorität.
Die Kommunikation soll so schnell wie möglich wiederhergestellt werden.
In den meisten Hochwasser...
Ja, aber zeig doch mal was.
Okay, die labern einfach nur.
... können abgesetzt werden. Die Kolleginnen und Kollegen...
Aha.
Das ist auch...
Okay, hier haben wir jetzt...
Das ist so schlecht aufgelöst, ich erkenne das gar nicht richtig.
Also hier haben wir jetzt auf jeden Fall irgendwelche Netzwerkschichten, würde ich mal sagen.
Erkennt man nicht so wirklich.
Ist das ein 10G-Stecker?
Ich erkenne es nicht wirklich.
Ich erkenne nichts.
Keine Ahnung.
Es ist für mich nicht näher auszumachen, was ich da sehend bin.
Es könnten irgendwelche Plate-Einschübe sein, vielleicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Gut, hier ist ein Netzwerkkabel.
Ne, wobei, ist das überhaupt ein Netzwerkkabel?
Wahrscheinlich.
Die Leute können das wahrscheinlich auch nicht sehen.
... Kollegen arbeiten Tag und...
Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was richtig praktisch wäre?
Anstatt, dass sie da jetzt mit der Taschenlampe rumstelzen, warum haben die nicht irgend so eine Baustellenlampe, die man...
Ah, haben sie doch, hier, oder?
Das ist der Hinterteil...
Ist das das Hinterteil von der Lampe, was man hier sieht, oben?
Könnte sein, oder?
Und Stirnlampe wäre für, wenn du hier schalten machen musst, sicherlich auch nicht verkehrt, ja.
... Infektionsinfrastruktur wieder bereit...
Ah, okay, jetzt habe ich, glaube ich, erkannt, was es ist.
Sieht nach Glasfaser, äh...
Tag und Nacht...
Diese Mono... Mono-Dings?
Ne.
Wie heißen die Stecker?
Diese...
Um die Tele...
Die, die, die, die kleinen Glasfaserstecker, frag mich nicht.
Ich kann mir...
Da gibt es mittlerweile...
Da gibt es...
Du hast ja bei Glasfaser acht verschiedene Stecker.
... Kommunikationsinfrastruktur wieder bereit...
Glaube...
Oder?
Ne.
Doch, doch, doch.
Das ist eindeutig.
Ja, ja.
Und das ist, das ist irgendein Cisco ChipX, oder sowas.
Genau.
Das ist...
Könnte ein LC-Stecker sein, ja.
Das ist ein LC-Stecker, genau.
Das ist ein LC-Stecker.
Siehste mal.
LC-Stecker und irgendein...
Und irgendein...
SFP-Plus-Modul, oder so.
Oder...
Das, das Ding schiebst du in den Switch rein, hier vorne...
Das ist übrigens falsch rum, so wie er das hält.
Ich weiß nicht, warum er das falsch rum hält.
Wahrscheinlich guckt er oben auf die Beschreibung.
Also, hier vorne muss das, muss das Kabel rein.
Ah ja, macht er auch, macht er auch.
Hat er...
Ist da noch der Schalter?
Ist da noch der Schutz-Dings oben drauf?
Ne, ne...
Nee, ich glaub nicht.
Werden viele Provisorien gebaut, um schnell zu helfen.
Zusätzlich werden Mobilfunk-Starter-Sets, Datengutscheine und auch Router...
Wo gibt's Update 2?
Okay, gut.
Betriebsstelle Gerolstein.
Alles klar, zeit mal.
Das ist 1.52, da können wir schnell gucken.
Bilder aus unserer Betriebsstelle in Gerolstein von Router.
Wir haben das hier oben auf der Seite.
Okay.
Da ist ein Bio.
Vorher habe ich gerade...
Bei der Woche habe ich mit einer Firma das hier gemacht und habe das hier hier auf
der Seite gelockert.
Wo gibt's Update 2?
Betriebsstelle Gerolstein.
Alles klar, das ist 1,52.
Können wir schnell gucken.
Okay, der hört sich schon mal besser an.
Audio-akustisch als der andere.
Gerolstein, kommt da nicht das Wasser her?
Also nicht das im Keller.
Also ich meine das abgefüllte Wasser.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass die alle Gerolsteiner im Keller haben.
In Gerolstein jetzt.
Alter, der ganze Flamm.
Boah, boah, Alter, was ist mit der Tür los?
Ist das durch den Wasserdruck oder durch was kommt das?
Durch was ist die Tür hier ripp?
Oder haben die die Tür aufgemacht, weil sie nicht mehr richtig aufzumachen ging?
Krasser Scheiß.
Das ist die ganze Flamme.
So, Max, danke schön für den Zap.
Die Festnetztechnik ist aufgrund der Wassermassen weitgehend zerstört.
Aber auch hier gibt es eine positive Nachricht.
Die redundante Glasfaseranbindung der Betriebsstelle ist intakt geblieben.
Unsere schnelle Eingreifung...
Ja, das ist ja schön.
Trotzdem sind die Leute dann weiterhin nicht angeschlossen.
Gut, aber Glasfaser kaputt zu kriegen, ist auch schwierig.
Also du kriegst das, wo das rauskommt aus der Erde und so kaputt,
aber den Rest so.
Das liegt ja normalerweise sogar unter Wasser.
Also natürlich dann in einem passenden Kabel,
also passenden Mantel und alles.
Also die Kabels an sich kriegst du nicht kaputt mit Unwetter.
Das Disaster Recovery Management aus Göttingen
ist am Samstagmorgen um halb zwei an der Schadensstelle eingetroffen.
Der Container enthält alle notwendige Technik, um die Betriebsstelle...
Mach einen Knick rein, dann ist es kaputt.
Ja, mach mal einen Knick rein, wenn das Ding fünf Meter tief verbuddelt ist.
Viel Spaß.
...zu ersetzen.
Der Container ist mittlerweile mit Strom und Glasfaser angebunden.
Die Einrichtung der mobilen Vermittlungsstelle
wird aber noch ein paar Stunden in Anspruch nehmen.
Wir halten euch auf dem Laufenden.
Die Kolleginnen und Kollegen vom Disaster Recovery Management
haben aber Katastrophen erzielt.
Sie arbeiten in drei Schichten...
Ja, das ist, das kommt bei der, Katastrophen kommt bei der Telekom öfters vor.
Wundert mich nicht, dass sie da Erfahrung mit haben.
...und um die Uhr, bis alles läuft.
An dieser Stelle ein herzliches Dankeschön für das positive Feedback, das uns erreicht.
Wir geben das an unsere...
Guck mal, die haben, die haben magenta Helme.
Die haben wirklich magenta, magenta Helme.
Hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht.
Oder es sieht nur so aus.
...Kolleginnen und Kollegen im Einsatz weiter.
Das hilft. Danke.
Das ist wirklich ein magenta Helme.
Das ist natürlich das Allerwichtigste jetzt.
Branding ist alles, ja.
Oh, Betriebsstelle 2, das kommt 2 Minuten 53, können wir noch kommen.
Eine Frage, die uns...
Oh, wir haben eine ordentliche, wir haben einen mit einem ordentlichen Mikro.
...Moment immer wieder gestellt wird, ist...
Ne, ne, ne, der ist einfach nur besser ausgerichtet.
...zu die Telekom konkret und vor Ort, um in den vom Hochwasser betroffenen Gebieten
schnellstmöglich die Infrastruktur wieder zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Dies möchten wir exemplarisch an unserem Standort in Gelsenkirchen, in der Stadt, in der Stadt, in der Stadt, in der Stadt, in der Stadt, in der Stadt, in der Stadt, in der Stadt, in der Stadt, in der Stadt, in der Stadt, in der Stadt, in der Stadt, in der Stadt, in der Stadt.
Alter, ich finde das immer so krass.
Da ist es ja normalerweise relativ sauber in solchen...
Ich war noch nie bei der Telekom in sowas drinnen, aber normalerweise ist es in solchen Locations immer relativ sauber.
Aber das Wasser ist halt trotzdem dreckig wie Sau.
Also das ist halt ein Schlamm, das ist richtig eklig, ja.
...Gerolstein ist ein sehr wichtiger Standort für die Technik der Telekom.
Hier sowohl für den Mobilfunkbereich als auch für den Festnetzbereich.
Gut, den Steckern und Kabeln macht...
Ich glaube, das ist wahrscheinlich nicht allzu viel.
Eher das, was dahinter ist.
Dieser Raum stand bis vor wenigen Stunden bis unter die Decke voll Wasser.
Unsere Technik, jetzt auch nach dem Abpumpen, nicht mehr einsatzfähig.
Die Beschädigungen ziehen sich durch das komplette Gebäude und über unsere komplette Technik hinweg.
Ein Instandsetzen dieser Technik wäre weder in Stunden noch in Tagen möglich.
Um aber so schnell wie möglich weitere Mobilfunkstandorte wieder in Betrieb zu bekommen und zu versorgen...
Und erste Festnetz...
Ich will eigentlich nur ein bisschen...
...wieder...
...wieder ein bisschen Technikkram sehen.
Guck mal, der hat ein Mikrofon anstecken.
Deswegen hört es sich auch gleich viel besser an als der erste.
Wie gesagt, die sind bei der Telekom erprobt, da gibt es öfters Desaster.
...einer sogenannten Safety-Maßnahme aus Göttingen durch ganz Deutschland einsetzbar geordert.
Die Kolleginnen und Kollegen haben bereits in der Nacht angefangen, hierfür aufzubauen.
Glaubt mir, Leute, sowas macht Spaß.
Erstens...
Ich meine, die Umstände nicht, aber sowas, wenn du Technik interessiert bist und wenn du gerne bastelst, macht sowas Spaß.
Weil du bist in solchen Ausnahmesituationen nichts mehr alle zwei Stunden in einem Meeting.
Du hast nicht laufend Leute um dich herum rumrennen, die sagen, du hast jetzt den Change-Prozess nicht richtig erfolgt, befolgt.
Du hast nicht Leute, die rumrennen.
Du brauchst jetzt erstmal 20 Jira-Tickets, die den falschen Status haben.
Also wenn man einfach mal arbeiten will und Technik-Bastel interessiert...
So was sind das die besten Einsätze.
Also sowas habe ich noch nicht gemacht.
Also so hier krisenmäßig da gebastelt, nach Überschwemmung logischerweise, klar.
Aber als ich beim Provider gearbeitet habe, haben wir auch schon von neuem Rechenzentrum bis wo Sachen kaputt waren und so,
da haben wir auch schon ein paar Sachen umgebaut, ausgebaut, aufgebaut und das fand ich immer am besten.
Du musst einfach nicht auf irgendwie...
zigtausend BWL-Scheiß achten, sondern kannst einfach arbeiten.
Das fand ich immer am besten damals.
Und die beste Story dazu ist ja immer noch, wo ich mit dem Felix durch...
Ähm...
Also wir mussten mal in ein Rechenzentrum fahren, Felix und ich.
Mit Felix habe ich mal ein Gamescom-Video gemacht.
Felix war ja auch Azubi bei uns und ähm...
Wir mussten mal in ein Rechenzentrum fahren in Frankfurt und mussten dort zwei Plates in Platesendern austauschen.
Also, ich zeige euch mal, das waren auch die alten...
Das sind die Plates, das sind die alten Platesender.
Da hast du quasi so eine, ich glaube 8 HE ist das, du hast hier so eine Kiste gehabt und das hier ist quasi ein eigener Rechner.
So jedes... so ein Einschubding.
Und das ist so ein Plate.
Die kannst du... du kannst unter ein Plate von der Größe her unter den Arm nehmen, eins links, eins rechts.
Aber das wiegt auch schon ein bisschen was auf Dauer.
So und da sind wir mit zwei Plates ins Rechenzentrum.
Und da sind wir mit zwei Plates ins Rechenzentrum.
Jeder hat links und rechts eins unter den Arm genommen davon.
Und mussten dann durch Frankfurt fahren mit der S-Bahn und jeder zwei Platesender unterm Arm.
Und jeder zwei Platesender unterm Arm.
Ich sage euch Leute, das war echt eine abenteuerliche Geschichte.
Also erstens haben uns die Leute angeguckt, so nach dem Motto, was treiben die da?
Und später als wir ausgestiegen sind, hat es angefangen zu regnen.
Und dann mussten wir die Plates unter die Jacke stecken.
so wie wir darum was schmuggeln wie irgendwelche drogen oder so aber hat alles funktioniert
eingebaut sonst wie das war noch zeit da hast du leute mit zwei plates quer durch frankfurt
geschickt in frankfurt gar nicht so unüblich aber nicht so offensichtlich aber so sachen habe ich
immer gern gemacht hat seine ruhe aber so einsetzen wenn man wirklich gerne bastelt das
ist ja im prinzip immer ein bisschen basteln dann basteln mit mit ahnung halt ich meine basteln wird
immer so negativ gesehen aber leute die basteln können die bastel auch gescheite sachen und so
einsätze sind immer gut so einsetzen immer nice wenn man einfach nur mal in ruhe technik kram
machen will ohne zu viele prozesse regeln dailies krams meetings hast du nicht gesehen dass in
solche einträge das beste einsätze das beste nachdem der safety container abgeladen ist in
der safety container meinte safety also sicherheit oder oder oder ist das safe
für tlc
und aufgestellt wurde beginnt nun die arbeit wo versucht wird die technik die über jahre in dem
gebäude gewachsen ist und unsere kunden versorgt provisorisch ist alles in magenta dieser container
wurde basierend auf der vorarbeit unseres katastrophenschutzmanagement in den letzten
tagen und nächten hier vor konfiguriert angeliefert nun beginnt die detailarbeit
ok was haben wir denn hier jede menge glasfaser stellt was ich doch sehr
aussieht doch ist dass du äußerst ordentlicher criticized jede menge ports vermute ich war
portsm могу mie dinger drin das ist haltچak das sind die dicken das in die dichen glasfaser ports
kann wenn die glasfaser das sind die lc stecker und das sind die alten dicken stecker sehen
zumindest so aus ich weiß aber nicht wie die heißen aus dem kopf sc ist das erstens checker
ja die da die rechten hier die da das lc stecker genau dass das sind die großen glasfaserstecker
das sind die kleinen glasfaserstecker oder gut was das jetzt ist das sind diese gummi
noppen die da immer vorne drauf hast die ich immer verlieren also wenn du wissen willst was
der max eingebaut hat dann musst du dir die hardware angucken wo die hälfte der gummi
stopfen fehlt dann ist das war ich das ansonsten sieht man nicht allzu viel
zeugs ehrlich
guck mal hier mit statik mit statik armband hier und so was richtig macht er richtig professionellen
eindruck wobei wir ja wissen das haben wir ja bei dem word oder was das war aufbau video
gelernt es reicht wenn man das anzieht man muss das nirgendwo anstöpseln ansonsten
sehe ich jetzt hier nichts schön beschriftet label gerät deswegen sage ich so ein label
drucker ist eines der wichtigsten sachen die man die man hier technik vor ort braucht raum
oder so was auch immer sonst sehe ich da jetzt nix spannendes wireless anti statik armband ja
guck mal guck mal der hat keins an mal gucken andere hand andere hand gucken die andere hand
kann er das auch nicht haben
wir haben keins an unsere technik yolo soll ich leute leute ich wollte mich jetzt mal aber nicht
nicht nicht gut die bass technisch ich hatte mich jetzt mal ich hatte nie bei wartungsarbeiten ein
anti statik armband an weiß nicht wie es euch geht aber naja herinnen und techniker aktuell
im dreischichtbetrieb 24 stunden im einsatz um dort wo noch nicht geschieht jolo leben am limit
zu nehmen das ist leider jedoch nicht überall möglich
aufgrund der aktuellen lage gibt es betriebsstätten welche wir nicht anfahren können beziehungsweise die
nicht mit netzersatz neben der pri
ist das eine usv
könnte es nur es konnte es dass das das ende von der usv sein was wir hier sehen was steht
nur steht daneben licht band eine ahnung eltec was ist eltec waren die ansonsten sieht man jetzt hier
auch nicht
priorisierten wiederherstellung des mobilfunknetzes sowie dem aufbau des fest soviel magenta über alle
kolleginnen und kollegen in den betroffenen gebieten auch unterwegs um unseren kundinnen
und kunden router lte routerscheine mobilfunk endgeräte und power banks zur verfügung zu
stellen moment das gucken wir uns nicht an es gibt zehn es gibt es gibt zehn davon wie viele
videos haben die in dieser richtung 12
mittlerweile aber tos musik drin ich will aber eigentlich nur technik sehen gibt aber mach mal
mach mal schluss der noch telekom du willst auch eine magenta power bank das problem ist bei der
magenta powerbank musste wahrscheinlich erst noch mal aufladen was wenn du kein strom hast schwierig
wird nur lte router nicht 5g ich glaube das kleinste problem was die leute gerade haben
ist ob 5g oder lte so die leute haben oder 5g oder lte ich glaube das kleinste problem was die leute haben ist ob 5g oder lte
ich glaube das kleinste problem was die leute haben ist ob 5g oder lte
Also, was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an?
Das Thema ist mir jetzt zu viel Batman.
Okay, Open Beta.
Ach ja, wir wissen jetzt, wann die Open Beta kommt.
Stimmt.
Ich habe es vergessen, aber es gibt ein Datum jetzt für die Open Beta.
Also wahrscheinlich.
Das wurde geleakt und wurde dann wieder offline genommen.
Können wir uns mal angucken.
Komm, wir lassen uns Jibain von Level Cap.
Der Level Cap Jibain ist immer traditionell schon.
Ich habe es heute schon einen IP-Leak.
Ja, ich habe gestern Vodafone noch genervt.
Ich habe jetzt eine neue IP.
Nicht, dass die Leute jetzt wieder mit irgendeiner DDoS-Scheiße kommen,
wenn ich den nächsten Technik-Stream mache.
Die EA Play Live war voll mit Battlefield 2042-Infos.
Die Open Beta der Spiele wird im September live.
EA Play-Subscriber und Pre-Order-Kunden
werden die EA Play Live-Subscriber und Pre-Order-Kunden
und die EA Play Live-Subscriber und Pre-Order-Kunden
Ja, sag uns, wann die Beta ist.
Die haben ein Datum genannt,
aber danach wieder rückgängig gemacht.
Aber das wird es wahrscheinlich ziemlich sicher sein.
Ja, das haben wir doch gerade schon gesehen.
Wann ist die Beta?
Beta.
Er hat geschrieben Open Beta Date.
Date bedeutet nicht, es ist irgendwann im September,
sondern Date bedeutet ein Datum.
Also, wenn ihr mehr Storch für euer PC braucht
und eine Kopie von Battlefield 2042 wollt,
schaut euch das an.
Ja, ja, bla, bla, bla.
Was?
Es gibt eine SSD mit Battlefield Branding?
Warum?
Da guckt doch kein Mensch, guckt doch in seinen Rechner rein
und denkt sich, ah, yes, SSD Battlefield 2042.
Battlefield vorinstallieren?
Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Muss ja mit dem Steam-Account oder Origin verknüpft sein.
Wie?
Ja, wo?
Wo ist denn jetzt das Beta Date?
Chebated, Alter.
Chebated.
Dazu gibt es eigentlich nur noch zu sagen.
Ja, 6.9., das habe ich, glaube ich, auch irgendwo gelesen,
aber in dem Video hätte ich jetzt eigentlich
Beta Date Battlefield 2042.
6.9., das kann aber tatsächlich sein.
Ähm, genau.
Die haben das nämlich Preload Details wieder gelöscht.
So, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Ach, nee, 22, nee, erscheinen.
Hier, 6. September.
Der ist mit 6.9. gar nicht so schlecht.
Wir müssen uns mal überlegen, das wirkt so, als ist das Game noch total weit weg.
Das Game kommt in zwei, naja, nicht ganz.
Na doch.
Naja, nicht, nee.
In drei Monaten, in drei Monaten.
Das Game kommt in drei Monaten raus.
Das ist nicht mehr weit weg.
Das ist eigentlich um die Ecke.
Battlefield 2042.
Ja, drei Monate.
Es ist das unsinnigste Remake aller Zeiten, Dead Space 1.
Dead Space 1 sieht immer noch ziemlich gut aus.
Gerade weil Dead Space ein Game ist, was eben viel durch Sound und Beleuchtung,
gemacht hat, jetzt nicht durch, wie soll man sagen, so, so, so Raw Landschaftsgrafik oder sonst was.
Dead Space 1 sieht immer noch ziemlich gut aus.
Schau ich das mal an.
Also, es ist nicht, dass das jetzt irgendwie, äh, Augenkrebs wäre oder so.
Das ist schon in Ordnung.
Also nix, was man irgendwie remaken müsste.
Vollkommen in Ordnung.
In the Frostbite Engine, they're rebuilding all of the...
Frostbite?
...the original assets instead of just porting them to the...
...the original assets instead of just porting them to the new engine.
Okay, da bin ich mal gespannt.
The goal is to preserve the game's original vision while improving its technical features...
Das kriegen die nicht hin.
Dead Space war so ne feinfühlige Mischung aus Sound, Effekten, also Sound, Licht, Effekten, Pacing.
Das kriegen die nicht nachgebaut.
Selbst wenn die 1 zu 1, kriegen sie nicht hin.
They're originally constrained due to time and resource constraints.
Players can expect a more immersive and atmospheric looking version of the game.
Yeah, ja, bla bla bla.
Play dieophobia, den sie nicht hin.
Den kriegen sie nicht hin.
The remake won't feature any microtransactions.
the Dead Space remake doesn't have a release date yet.
Ubisoft won a lawsuit against a Rainbow Six Siege DDoS operation.
They filed the suit back in 2019 and the verdict would be...
Jetzt haben die gedacht, jetzt können sie Ubisoft nicht mehr DDoS'en, jetzt machen sie mit mir weiter.
Wuss...
...was a GG for Ubisoft.
Die coolen Leute, zumindest in Popke, ich weiß nicht wie es in Rainbow Six ist,
die Strafe, ne wie heißt man das, die Strafe lehnen sich ja in die entgegengesetzte Richtung.
Also wenn du, also wenn du dahin, also die lehnen sich nach da, wenn sie dahin gucken wollen und sowas.
Das ist in Popke voll die Wissenschaft für sich, wie man sich richtig lehnen muss.
Ja, also.
Da wollte ich jetzt einfach was zu sagen.
Da sind ja alle Newsseiten wieder total drauf aufgesprungen, so nach dem Motto, New World tötet RTX 3090.
Es ist, es war so, wie soll man sagen, so Effekthascherei, ne wie nennt man das, so Sensationsgeilheit wieder.
Ohne mal wirklich die Tatsachen zu nennen.
Also das Game hat selbstverständlich nicht die Grafikkarte zerstört.
Ja, das Game war dran beteiligt, weil sie dummes Zeug programmiert haben, aber eigentlich nix, nix Wildes.
Das Problem war, dass die Kühlung halt einfach oder was auch immer einfach nicht ausreichend vom Hersteller, also Hardware-technisch dimensioniert war.
So, was natürlich dumm war von New World ist, dass man im Menü und das Game hatte, also das Problem war, New World ist gelauncht und es gab lange Wartezeiten, bis man auf den Surfer reingekommen ist.
Das heißt, man hat durchaus mal zwei Stunden im Hauptmodus.
Das heißt, man hat zwei Stunden im Hauptmodus gestanden, bis man sich einloggen konnte.
Und was die bei New World gemacht haben ist, die haben nichts, die haben keine FPS limitiert und die haben anscheinend auch ziemlich Grafikkarten fordernde Dinger gemacht im Hauptmenü.
Dementsprechend war die Grafikkarte zu 100% ausgelastet und die hatten dann quasi zwei Stunden 100% Auslastung auf der Grafikkarte.
Und wenn du da eine Grafikkarte hast, wo die Kühlung nicht ausreichend dimensioniert ist.
Oder dein Rechner nicht richtig gekühlt ist, dann hast du ein Problem.
Und dementsprechend sind ja auch nur die von EVGA verreckt, weil der Hersteller nicht richtig aufgepasst hat.
Also das ist nicht die Schuld von New World.
New World hat, muss man sogar sagen, richtig gut reagiert.
Sie haben einen Patch veröffentlicht, um der ganzen Sache vorzubeugen, indem sie die FPS limitiert haben.
Das war, by the way, das erste, was ich gemacht habe, ohne, noch lange bevor diese News rausgekommen sind.
Das erste, was ich gemacht habe, ist, ich bin reingegangen.
Es gibt sogar ein Menü, es gibt sogar einen Menüpunkt in dem Spiel, dass man sagen kann, hey, FPS unlimited, aber gecappt auf was auch immer.
So, und fertig.
Fertig. Easy.
Das erste, was ich gemacht habe, weil ich hab's direkt gehört.
Ich war in der Server-Queue und mein Rechner, die Grafikkarte hat halt gerauscht ohne Ende.
Da wusste ich, okay, das liegt einfach daran, das Ding hat im Hauptmenü halt brutalste GPU-Belastung.
Ja, äh, nicht unlimited, v-sync aus.
V-sync, meine ich nicht, nicht unlimited.
V-sync aus, aber gecappt auf XY.
Und das kannst du einstellen.
Das war das erste, was ich eingestellt habe.
Und ich bilde mir sogar ein, die haben sogar einen Menüpunkt gehabt für das Hauptmenü.
Limit-FPS-Hauptmenü.
Gab's, glaube ich, auch.
Ja, also das ist...
Und ja, das hat EVGA auch zu replacen.
Die haben's nämlich verkackt.
Du kannst eine Grafikkarte mit Software nicht kaputt machen, wenn du die offiziellen APIs...
dafür verwendest.
Wir reden jetzt nicht von, ich flashe ein falsches BIOS oder sowas.
Du kannst eine Grafikkarte, wenn du es drauf anlegst, mit Software, je nachdem, was du machst, sicherlich zerstören.
Ja, aber du kannst es nicht zerstören, indem du die offiziellen, zur Verfügung gestellten Funktionen von Windows DirectX, was auch immer, fällst.
Das geht einfach nicht.
Da muss es irgendein Hardware-Problem geben.
...trat der GPUs Power-Delivery-System.
EVGA hat beurteilt, dass es RMAs gibt, die dieses Problem verursachen.
New Worlds-Developers haben das Spiel gepatcht, um das Problem nicht zu verursachen.
Und wenn es nicht New World gewesen wäre, wäre das irgendein x-beliebiges anderes Spiel, was auch nicht limitierte FPS hat und irgendwo eine Szene hat, die quasi mit hohen FPS die Grafikkarte total auslastet.
Das ist natürlich im Menü mehr zu spüren als im eigentlichen Game.
Weil im eigentlichen Game hast du dann noch das Problem, die CPU muss was machen, muss der Grafikkarte erst was liefern.
Also du hast in einem normalen Game selten konstant über 2-3 Stunden 100% GPU-Auslastung.
Es sei denn, du meinst irgendwas oder machst irgendwelche GPU-Berechnungen.
Normalerweise hast du keine konstante 100% GPU-Auslastung.
Also in normalem Gameplay.
Aber in dem Fall im Menü, was einfach nur so schnell gerendert wird, wie geht, hattest du das.
Und es war jetzt Pech, dass es New World getroffen hat.
Es war einfach Pech.
Ja, es war eine blöde Idee, das nicht zu cappen im Menü, aber die sind nicht daran schuld, dass die Grafikkarten kaputt sind.
Das ist kein 3090-Exklusiv-Issue, das stimmt.
Aber es ist kein Problem von New World.
Das ist einfach Unlimited FPS im Hauptmenü.
Das Hauptmenü hat keine Gameplay-Features.
Die rendern einfach so schnell Grafik wie geht.
Also im normalen Gameplay hast du dann so Sachen wie, du hast irgendwelche Physik-Berechnungen, du hast irgendwelches Nachladen von Texturen, du hast X und jenes und sonst was.
Du kommst im normalen Gameplay halt nicht auf 2-3 Stunden am Stück konstant 100% GPU.
Im Hauptmenü halt schon.
Da ist aber New World nicht dran schuld, dass die Grafikkarte kaputt geht.
Die Hersteller haben es verschissen.
Die haben einfach nicht getestet, schaffst die Grafikkarte dauerhaft unter Vollbelastung.
Und ja, du kannst New World insofern einen Vorwurf machen, dass sie es vergessen haben.
Und cappen.
Aber das kann passieren und deswegen darf trotzdem keine Hardware kaputt gehen.
Zumal sie es ja auch schnell gepatcht haben.
Ich würde sogar eher sagen, in dem Fall, tatsächlich mal Hut ab vor Amazon Studios, das so schnell zu patchen.
Aber auch in ihrer Meldung, die sie geschrieben haben, finde ich, ist es korrekt, dass sie gesagt haben, das ist kein Problem von New World.
Quatsch!
Das liegt auch nicht an New World.
Das könnte jeder von uns programmieren.
Wahrscheinlich.
Also, die meisten zumindest.
Du bastelst einfach irgendwas, was null von der CPU abhängt und lässt das so schnell rendern, wie es geht.
Dann hast du deine Grafikkarte ausgelastet.
Also wenn die Leute auf ihren Rechnern irgendwelche Coins gemeint hätten, über die GPU, hätten sie genau das gleiche Problem gehabt.
Oder,
gut, weiß ich nicht, wie die Video-RAM-Belastung ist bei Mining, aber das legt jetzt nicht explizit an New World.
Sogar mein komischer GIF-Renderer schafft 50% CPU-Auslastung hier.
Big Brain, guckt euch mal an.
Der Overlay-Champ.
Sogar der Overlay-Champ macht 30% CPU-Auslastung und ich warte noch auf GIF-Rendern.
Pass mal auf.
Massive GIF-Rendern kommt jetzt hier.
Bam!
Ups.
Äh, naja.
Jetzt aber.
Ja.
410 FPS GIF-Rendern.
Und?
Wie viel CPU-Auslastung haben wir?
Okay, 9%.
Dann doch nicht so viel.
Aber ich muss auch auf das GIF-Rendern warten.
Die GPU kann überhaupt nicht so schnell, wie sie will.
Und das ist das, was du bei normalem Gameplay auch hast.
Offiziell, äh, was heißt, äh, nicht offiziell, aber bei normalem Gameplay hast du das auch so nicht.
Nicht in der, äh, in der Extremität, ja.
Aber, dass du eben oftmals warten musst, bis du von der, von der CPU genug Sachen hast,
bis irgendwas nachgeladen ist und sonst was.
Du hast halt normalerweise keine 100%-CPU.
Slow das mal.
Warum?
Ich will, ich will 450 FPS GIF-Rendern.
Was denn sonst?
Klar.
Weird Champ.
So.
Und wenn wir das nicht cappen würden, wenn wir es einfach nur so schnell rendern lassen würden, wie geht,
dann hätten wir auch 100% GPU-Auslastung.
Ja.
Mit einem GIF.
Und dann wären die Grafiker dann auch abgekackt.
...Fault Protection, Fault Detection and more.
Hopefully NVIDIA and AMD can figure out what's causing these failures and release firmware or drivers to fix the issue.
The state of California is suing Activision Blizzard for fostering a culture of sexual harassment, abuse and inequality...
Also eins habe ich jetzt gelernt durch diese, durch diese Activision, äh, äh, Blizzard-Klage.
Anscheinend scheint es im Managerkreis normal zu sein, dass man ein Buttplug und Gleitgelen...
...dabei hat.
Das, äh, scheint ja irgend so ein Typ ganz selbstverständlich dabei gehabt zu haben auf einer Dienstreise.
Wer kennt's nicht?
...towards women in their offices following a two-year investigation.
The allegations are severe and include a woman being assaulted and committing suicide during a company retreat,
women being passed over for promotions and raises in favor of male co-workers,
and men literally crawling around the office to make women in skirts or...
Die hatten ja, der, der Typ, der eine Typ hat ja sogar schon den Spitznamen, hat ja schon so einen speziellen Spitznamen,
Ja. Die hatten ja, der, der, der eine Typ hat ja sogar schon den Spitznamen, hat ja schon so einen speziellen Spitznamen,
...gehabt, dass es der ist, der die Leute bekrapscht.
Und das kommt einfach, wenn die Leute sich zu sicher und zu geil fühlen und zu un-, wie sagt man so, un-, un-, äh, zu unantastbar halt.
...dressen sich unangenehm.
Activision Blizzard hat ein Statement zu The Verge gegeben, das die Befragung gegen sie bezeichnet als unverantwortliches Verhalten von unverantwortlichen Staatsbürokraten,
die viele der besten Unternehmen der Staaten aus Kalifornien fahren.
Sie gehen auch weiter.
Es hat ja auch der, der Blizzard, der Blizzard-Chef, der hat ja auch irgendeine, eine Meldung rausgehauen, ähm, so nach dem Motto, sie sind eigentlich die, ich krieg das gar nicht mehr zusammen, sie sind eigentlich eine ganz tolle Firma und sie haben jetzt auch neuerdings, was hat er geschrieben, äh, Diversity, Anti-Mobbing-Training und, und was auch immer und überhaupt nicht, äh, zu dem eigentlichen, äh, zu dem eigentlichen, äh, zu dem eigentlichen, äh, zu dem eigentlichen, äh, zu dem eigentlichen, äh, zu dem eigentlichen, äh, zu dem eigentlichen, äh, zu dem eigentlichen, äh, zu dem eigentlichen, äh, zu dem eigentlichen, äh, zu dem eigentlichen, äh, zu dem eigentlichen, äh, zu dem eigentlichen, äh, zu dem eigentlichen, äh, zu dem eigentlichen, äh
vorfällen was einfach nur bla bla bla zwei seiten lang das beste training ist einfach die kack die
kackspasten rausschmeißen sobald die auffällig sind und ich rede jetzt nicht davon nur von von
leuten die die die mädels begrapschen sondern alle wenn einer nichts in der lage ist sinnvoll
mit anderen menschen umzugehen dann sollte es da klar man kann dir mal sagen hier reißt dich
mal zusammen aber dann ist dann ist vorbei ja dann schmeißt du den einfach raus weg da brauchst
dann brauchst du auch keinen keinen sonstwas training dafür die leute sollen einfach normal
miteinander umgehen wenn leute hat sich das nicht können dann haben sie pech es ist false
depictions of blizzards passt es plädiert more details in and around this case and if you want
to know more i encourage you to ja genau dass das ist so trainings und sachen gibt es einfach nur
dass die leute sagen kann guckt mal hier und ist das bewusst wir machen damit
was dagegen wie wir sind ja voll voll am puls der zeit und bla
die artikel für yourself season ten of apex legends is bringing in interesting new legend
with it seer will be the first new tracker character added to the game since launch
his tactical ability is a swarm of microdrones und es kann mir doch keine es muss jetzt aber
es kann mir doch keiner erzählen wenn du wenn es irgendwie wenn du wenn du in richtigen arsch
im team hast ja der andere leute immer abfuckt es kann mir noch keiner erzählen
dass dem das nicht okay du hast vielleicht manche den ist es nicht bewusst aber bei denen ist es so
innere einstellung wenn das den nicht bewusst ist dass du das den auch nicht einfach durch
den training abgewöhnt es ist ja nicht so das ist ja nicht so dass das den übelsten arsch im
team hast und der macht dann so einen anti mobbing training und danach kommt da raus ist der netteste
mensch auf der welt das ist ja bescheuert der sagt dann okay das wird das wird das höchste
der gefühle was passiert ist der sagt dann okay ich pass auf dass es keiner meiner chefs mehr sieht
und nervt noch subtiler bescheuert das klappt doch nicht ja das ist genauso wenn du da irgendwie
diversity und anti racism training und sonstige geschichten hast die leute sollen sich einfach wie
ordentliche menschen untereinander behandeln wenn du welche hast die aus prinzip oder von ihrer
inneren einstellung haus einstellung raus sich wie der letzte arsch verhalten dann wird sich
das mit irgendeinem training nicht ändern also
das kann mir keiner keiner erzählen dass das dann dass der von heute auf morgen sagt ah ja okay ich
sehe meine fehler ein mein ganzes leben war verkehrt ich mache das jetzt anders ist schwachsinn die
sollen sich einfach ordentlich verhalten oder wenn sie das nicht hinbekommen klar kann man die leute
mal ermahnen und kann sagen hey das war jetzt nicht okay je nachdem welchem umfang das war aber
wenn da wiederholt sachen passiert muss die leute einfach aufschmeißen kann sagen okay so nur nicht
in der firma und dann ist gut
und dann sammelte die eben auch eine gruppe aus leuten an wo das klima gut ist die gut miteinander
können und dementsprechend stimmen dann auch die ergebnisse umso besser die arbeitsatmosphäre ist
gerade für kreative berufe und game design ist ein kreativer beruf umso besser sind letztendlich auch
die ergebnisse oder umso kreativer ob die besser sind aber so kreativer sind natürlich auch die
ergebnisse unter druck und belastung bringt keiner gute kreative ergebnis ich hab's der letzten video
gesagt wenn du irgendeine maler ja wenn du dich mit einer pistole vor einem maler setzt und sagst hier
mal mal mal mal richtig geiles bild da wird nichts gescheites bei rauskommen weil es was kreatives ist
und stress anspannung kreativität widersprechen sich halt einfach und die leute verstellen sich
dann ein ja genau das einzige was passiert ist dieser ok achtung ich muss jetzt aufpassen da
machen die das halt subtiler da machen wir so subtil dass ich die chefs nichts mehr dagegen
sagen können was aber nicht weniger belastend ist kennt ihr so richtig passiv aggressive leute das
ist unglaublich schwer zu beschreiben
die die auch die lösen dich permanent aus ohne dass sie wirklich was sagen auslösen ist übrigens
scheint mein neues lieblingswort zu werden die lösen nicht permanent aus ohne dass sie wirklich
was handfestes sagen die schaltern mich genau die träger nicht wie c++ und es wozu das führt ist dass
sie das subtiler machen und das ist fast noch fast noch mehr belastend weil wenn es nicht subtil ist
und man nicht subtil ist das ist echt komisch und weil man nicht so gut auslösen kann also
wenn du das mal gesehen hast kannst du das irgendwie in zimmern nichts sagen aber wenn es halt super
ist ein bisschen satt und das ist verboten und wenn man das mal mit einem sektor wenn man dann
sagt alter halt maul und wenn dann jemand hört was war versteht er das auch so und wenn es jemand
aber dann lernt das noch subtiler und und versteckt dazu machen wenn du dann sagt alter halt maul dann
kriegst du noch den anschluss warum du denn so unprofessionell mit mit deinen mit deinen kollegen ist
Zum Beispiel, ich denke mir jetzt mal was Fiktives aus, es ist schwierig,
es fällt mir gerade schwierig, da ein Beispiel für zu finden.
Zum Beispiel, es ist irgendeine Besprechung und dann hast du dann einen Sitzen,
der sagt dann sowas wie, Max, aber jeder mit etwas Verstand würde das doch nicht so machen, oder?
Das klingt erstmal nicht schlimm, was es aber im Endeffekt heißt, ist,
dass, so nach dem Motto, schaut mal her Welt, die Vorschläge, die der Max jetzt gebracht hat,
ich nenne jetzt mal mich als Beispiel, die Vorschläge, die der Max gebracht hat,
sind eigentlich unterirdisch dumm.
Also das ist so eine Passiv, würde der Typ sagen, Max, laber keinen Scheiß,
dann kannst du da richtig drauf antworten, dann kannst du sagen, ja, halt die Klappe.
Kannst du sagen irgendwie, ich habe Scheiße labern ja vom Besten gelernt,
und guckst ihn da irgendwas, und da kannst du drauf reagieren,
auf so versteckte, passiv-aggressive Dinger ist wirklich schwierig.
Ich hatte da auch auf der Arbeit lange Jahre einen, mit dem habe ich mich echt nicht gut verstanden,
und wir hatten auch, also das beruhte auf Gegenseitigkeit, also wir konnten uns beide nicht sonderlich ab,
und das lief dann auch auf solche Dinger raus, und das war nervig, ja.
Der ist mittlerweile nicht mehr da, warum ist er nicht mehr da?
Ich habe mich da öfters auch mal beschwert bei meinem Chef, und habe auch gesagt,
mit dem arbeite ich nicht zusammen, das konnten alle verstehen, aber die konnten sich nicht dazu durch,
den zu kicken.
Mittlerweile ist er raus, warum?
Weil er das beim Falschen gemacht hat, nämlich zwei Ebenen weiter oben drüber.
Also es hat nicht gereicht, dass ich mich da beschwert habe, dass ich gesagt habe,
ich arbeite nicht mit dem mehr zusammen, aus dem und dem Grund,
na, das war denen wurscht,
sondern der war mal auf irgendeinem Meeting, wo zwei Ebenen oben drüber waren,
und hat denen auch erzählt, wie blöd sie alle sind, indirekt.
Und die haben gesagt, ja, okay, tschüss.
Du wusstest einfach nur bei der Falschen,
ich stelle mal, dann war, war vorbei.
Aber das Gute war, das, das Gute war, das beruhte auf, ähm,
Gegenseitigkeit, ja, ähm, der mochte mich nicht, ich mochte ihn auch nicht.
Und mit der Zeit war's dann halt so, wir haben dann im Prinzip einfach nicht interagiert miteinander.
Das ist auch ein Problem, ja, und so war's, so ist es ja bei Blizzard im Endeffekt, ähm,
dass der Typ, der in dem Fall hier die Weiber begrabt stand,
irgendjemand aus der Führungsebene ist.
Und dann hast du ja mehrere Probleme.
Also, du hast du, du, du hast das generelle Problem,
dass viele Leute wahrscheinlich nicht wissen, wie sie damit umgehen sollen.
Und dann hast du das nächste Problem, das ist der Chef von deinem Chef.
Also, das ist, das ist ja doppelt problematisch.
Zumal bei Blizzard war ja richtig, da ist ja richtig die Kacke am Dampfen gewesen, ne?
Ich weiß gar nicht, inwieweit ihr das verfolgt habt.
Das war nicht nur so, dass, ähm,
der Typ Kleidgel und einen Buttplug mitgenommen hat auf die Geschäftsreise.
Die haben auch, äh, Genitalbilder
verschickt, äh, von der Mitarbeiterin.
Also, sprich, das war nicht nur der eine Typ, der das wusste, das waren mehrere.
Also, alles schon hart.
Naja, Momente mal, das ist das, natürlich, es gibt kein Urteil oder sonst was, das ist das, was, äh, wer, wo ist das?
In Kalifornien, was, was die, frag mich nicht, Staat Kalifornien, Polizei Kalifornien, was die ermittelt haben.
Natürlich, der Urteilsspruch steht noch aus, klar.
Kannst, kannst sagen, in dem Fall, äh, für den, für den Angeklagten.
Aber es ist ja nicht so, als hätten sie sich das jetzt von heute auf morgen ausgedacht.
Aber du hast insofern schon recht, klar, warten wir mal, was rauskommt.
Aber solche, solche Geschichten sind schon echt hart, ja.
Auf der, das habe ich gar nicht gelesen, ob das die Weihnachtsfeier war.
Es war echt, also wirklich hartes, hartes Zeug, also.
Und Blizzard ist jetzt...
Jetzt halt um Schadensbegrenzung bemüht.
Aber bei Blizzard geht's gar nicht ab.
Es geht um Schadensbegrenzung.
Hat der schon mal DLSS verwendet?
Ich glaube, ich habe das noch nirgends vor eingeschaltet.
...released to compete with AMD's new FidelityFX Super Resolution Tech,
which is platform-agnostic and free to implement.
Im Prinzip ist doch DLSS, also wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ist DLSS doch folgendes.
DLSS ist das Gegenteil von Supersampling.
Supersampling ist ja quasi, man rendert was in einer höheren Aufwertung,
in einer höheren Auflösung, und rechnet es runter auf die kleinere Auflösung.
So, und DLSS ist, man rendert es auf kleinere Auflösung und scaled es hoch auf höhere Auflösung.
Genau, es ist quasi Upscaling gut gemacht, was im Endeffekt heißt,
du brauchst weniger Performance zum Rendern, weil du kleinere Auflösung renderst.
Und du hast aber ein gutes Upscaling, dass es nicht so auffällt.
Gemischt mit AI.
Big Brain Time.
Heute ist alles AI.
Meine Lieblings-AI-Seite ist die hier.
This cat does not exist.
Beste AI-Seite.
AI-gestützter Katzen-Generator.
Alle diese Katzen existieren nicht.
Manchmal sieht man es, dass es ein bisschen fake ist.
Hier unten sieht man nämlich, das passt irgendwie nicht so ganz dabei.
Manchmal sieht man die Fehler.
Aber es ist AI-generierte Katzen.
Mit Personen gibt es das auch.
Ja, guck mal, die Augen hier.
Stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Also entweder sieht die Katze nix oder die Augen hat das AI-Ding irgendwie ein bisschen verkackt.
Also das ist nicht fehlerfrei.
Aber zum größten Teil ist es, oder auch hier, guck.
Was ist das?
Aber zum größten Teil ist es echt gut.
Ich weiß, es gibt es auch für Menschen, aber wen interessieren Menschen?
Ich finde Katzen-Generator viel besser.
Hat man schon.
Ja, manche ähneln sich auch ein bisschen.
Ja, hat man auch schon.
Und DLSS, beide rendern dein Spiel auf einer niedrigeren Resolution und
intelligenter die Bildung auf eine höhere Resolution.
DLSS ist notabler besser, wenn man auf niedrigeren Settings schaut, aber AMD ist
immer noch ziemlich früh mit seinen Techniken und ich schätze, dass es
auf der Straße Verbesserungen geben wird.
Survival Horror RPG Spiel Chernobyl.
Oh nein.
Survival Horror RPG.
Da haben wir unbedingt noch eins gebraucht von.
Da gibt's schon zu wenige für.
Es wird für die Playstation 4 und Xbox One am 7. September auf dem PC.
Das Spiel verlässt early access.
On Wednesday.
The game will also be available on next gen consoles, but it's unclear what upgrades
werden, dass sie haben.
Zombies wetten.
Sie haben Zombies.
Es gibt Zombies oder Mutanten.
Muss es auch noch geben.
It's meant you can expect the developers recently said in an interview that they
don't expect players to notice a big difference in the game, wenn ich das sehe.
Ohne Scheiß, ich will jetzt nicht so sehr über die Games renten, die ich nicht
kenne, wenn ich dieses Menü System und Dinger sehe, schlägt bei mir hart der
Residenz Lieber zu.
Das ist so, soll ich sagen?
So.
Charakterlos von wie beschreibt man das am besten von Spielen so so einfallslos
und und ich weiß nicht, dass so uninspiriert, seelenlos.
Ja, genau.
Game feels between last gen and next gen platforms.
Portal based arena shooter Splitgate had to be taken offline because of how
popular its recent beta was.
It peaked at 65000 concurrent players.
The open beta included.
Crossplay with PC and consoles.
The resulting spike in popularity caused widespread stability issues.
Force.
Ja, wird nicht, wird nicht lange halten, wenn das Geld raus ist, ist wahrscheinlich
dead nach einem Monat, weil ich sage, ich kenne es nicht.
Take it down for maintenance.
Hat ein bisschen, hat ein bisschen was von ein bisschen was von Halo vom Menü her.
Yeah, they've implemented a queue system to ensure players can join matches and
expanded support for more players before we get to this week's final story.
Thanks for tuning in.
We'll be back on Monday with a new video.
Don't forget to check out the Western Digital.
Ssd Valve says their portable gaming PC can handle every game on Steam as long as
you're okay with some games dropping to 30 FPS.
Stimmt nicht.
Das stimmt nicht.
Quote mich, wenn es rauskommt.
Das wird unter SteamOS nicht alles laufen, was auf Steam ist.
Es wird vielleicht alles laufen, was es dir anzeigt.
In dem Steam Client auf Steam auf auf.
Auf dem Steam Deck.
Aber es wird nicht.
Nicht alles laufen, was auf Twitch, was auf Steam ist.
Quote mich, wenn es so weit ist.
Das wird es nicht.
As long as you're okay with some games.
Das wird es vielleicht, wenn du Windows installiert, meinetwegen eventuell, aber.
Dann ist zumindest technisch kein Problem.
Aber das wird nicht unter SteamOS alles mit Proton laufen.
Nicht alles, was auf Steam ist.
Garantiert nicht.
Werd ich bloß.
Dropping to 30 FPS.
The Steam Deck uses an AMD Zen 2 APU with an RDNA.
Hör doch erst mal zu overrated.
GPU.
That's actually a pretty powerful combination.
Well optimized titles or games with good graphics options.
Ich glaube, wenn man Sachen emulieren will, ist das richtig geil.
Games that offer AMD's FSR or other dynamic resolution scaling options should also run
quite well on the Steam Deck.
That being said, don't expect desktop class performance from the Steam Deck, but also
don't go in thinking that every game is going to run poorly either.
And that wraps it up for this week in gaming.
As always, guys, thank you so much for watching and I'll see you next time.
This is LevelCap signing off.
Ciao.
Bye.
Das stimmt nicht.
Das einzige Problem sind aktuell nur Spiele mit, also im Prinzip Anti-Cheat.
Ja, alle Spiele oder sagen wir mal so, die meisten Spiele mit Anti-Cheat Software sind
ein Problem.
Das heißt nicht, dass alle Spiele mit einem Problem automatisch wegen Anti-Cheat Software
Probleme haben.
Es gibt genug Spiele, die wirst du nicht ohne Tweaks drauflaufen bekommen.
Out of the box, so wie das zum Beispiel irgendwie, keine Ahnung, nur noch 15 User erwartet, der
das so macht.
15 User erwartet, der das Ding einschaltet und seinen Steam Account verknüpft.
Zum Beispiel, gutes Beispiel ist, weil ich es letztens erst mal wieder gespielt habe.
Das ist ein gutes Beispiel.
So.
Dragon Age Origins.
Wie geht man?
Proton.
Proton DB.
Ich weiß, sie wollen das verbessern.
Wie verbessern?
Das zeigt sich dann.
Dragon Age.
So.
Ultimate Edition.
Das ist ja das, was man aktuell auf Steam so kauft.
So.
Gold.
Das funktioniert gut, aber nach Tweaks.
Also es ist einfach nicht so, dass du sagen kannst, hey, wir starten das und es geht.
Also es ist nicht so, als verknüpfe ich meinen Steam Account und es geht.
Das ist für uns in der Regel kein Problem.
Ja.
Für uns hier so ein paar Tweaks zu machen mit, keine Ahnung, was muss man hier, irgendwelche
Wine Prefixes oder sonst was.
Das ist für uns kein Problem.
Für den normalen User, der das Ding einfach anschaltet, verknüpft mit seinem Steam Account,
ist das ein Problem.
Das passt halt einfach nicht.
Für mich ist Laufen für so einen normalen User nicht etwa.
Man bekommt es zum Laufen.
Also es ist prinzipiell möglich, dass es läuft.
Heißt nicht, es ist gut für den normalen User zu verwenden.
Valve kann die Tweaks ausliefern.
Ob sie das können und ob sie das machen, steht auf einem komplett anderen Blatt.
Es ist auch fraglich, welche Tweaks man braucht.
Also das ist nicht so klar, wie es aussieht.
Aktueller Stand ist, es laufen viele Spiele.
Und von den Spielen.
Und von den Spielen, die gut laufen, laufen aber viele auch erst mit Tweaks.
Und das ist nichts für den normalen User, der das Ding startet, sein Steam Account verknüpft
und damit spielen will.
Und das werdet ihr auch sehen bei Release, dass genau diese Leute damit Probleme haben.
Das wird genauso sein, wie ich das sage.
Wenn nicht, ich gebe es gerne zu.
Aber so sieht es aktuell aus.
Und natürlich, Anti-Cheat kommt noch dazu.
Da wird es auch weiterhin in Zukunft Probleme geben.
Aber es ist bei weitem nicht Anti-Cheat-Software.
Ja, genau.
Das ist auch noch so ein Ding.
Also, warten wir es mal ab.
Ich habe meine Bedenken und ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass ich recht habe damit.
Schauen wir mal.
Wahrscheinlich wird es aber eh so sein, wie bei jeder Valve-Hardware.
Das Ding kommt raus und da interessiert es mich halt kein mehr.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, genau.
Das ist jetzt aber schon eine Einschränkung zu dem, was du vorher gesagt hast.
So nach dem Motto, es läuft alles.
Ja klar, es laufen dann die, die getestet sind.
Das ist aber weit davon entfernt.
Nach dem Motto, man kann jedes Spiel in Steam spielen.
Ja, das ist ja ein Unterschied.
Natürlich kann man die spielen, die getestet sind.
Klar, die, die getestet sind und markiert sind als laufend gut.
Das wäre ja auch bitter, wenn das dann auch nicht funktioniert.
Aber von, es läuft alles auf Steam und dazu ist jetzt ja schon ein ganz schöner Unterschied.
Ich habe dir doch gerade ein Beispiel gezeigt von einem Game, was, keine Ahnung, wie alt ist das?
Zehn Jahre ist Dragon Age Origin.
Das läuft, das läuft auch gut.
Das läuft aber erst mit Tweaks.
Mit irgendwelchen Exports.
Für Vine-Prefix, was auch immer.
Das kannst du einem 0-15-Noob einfach nicht zumuten.
Die kaufen sich das, schalten das ein, verknüpfen den Steam-Account und starten das Spiel und stellen vor, es geht nicht.
Die gehen nicht auf ProtonDB und suchen sich irgendeinen Vine-Prefix-Export, was auch immer raus, um das zu machen.
Es geht mir gar nicht darum, um das schlecht zu reden.
Ich persönlich verdiene mit Linux mein Geld.
Mir geht es darum, das realistisch zu sehen und nicht zu sehr aus Fanboy-Sicht zu sagen.
So nach dem Motto, ja, ProtonDB.
Proton ist das Allheilmittel.
Proton ist viel, viel besser als das, was es vor zehn Jahren mit Wine-Only gegeben hat.
Aber es wird nicht reichen in der jetzigen Form.
Und auch, und da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, auch in der Form, was zum Release rauskommt, wird es nicht dazu führen, dass auf magische Art und Weise, dass das irgendwie funktioniert.
Wie gesagt, ich wäre froh, wenn es nicht so ist.
Ich bin der Erste, der sich freuen würde, wenn man das kicken kann.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Warum ist das Game dann, aber wenn man das jetzt alles nicht mehr braucht, warum ist das Game dann noch Gold und nicht, äh, was haben die, Flawless, so?
Ich, wir werden es sehen.
Wir werden es sehen.
Ich habe da meine Zweifel und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass ich damit recht liege, äh, richtig liege.
So, jetzt gucken wir mal jetzt als nächstes.
How to make your window appliance easy.
Ja, easy, wenn ich mir so ein komisches Ding einbauen will für viel zu viel Geld.
Jetzt den Portal Speedrun.
Okay.
Portal Speedrun that doesn't use speedruns.
Okay, gucken wir jetzt.
Alles klar.
Speedrun stellt's.
Can you beat Portal without using any portals?
Ja.
Wenn es so ein Video gibt, ist die Antwort wahrscheinlich ja.
Und universelle YouTube-Weisheit, wenn ein Fragezeichen im Titel ist, ist die Antwort meistens nein.
Okay, well, technically, you can just turn on...
Hä?
So wie, guck mal.
Beispiel ist mein Video, mein Video zu Steam Deck.
Wer baut die bessere Switch Pro?
Fragezeichen im Titel?
Die Antwort ist nein.
Ganz einfach.
So, wo ist denn der Portal?
...cheats and noclip your way through all of the levels.
Ja, das zählt ja nicht.
But that's no fun.
So let's set a simple limitation.
You're not allowed to use any cheats.
By using the command svcheats1 in the developer console, the player has access to a ton of cheat commands.
Like timescale, godmode, and of course, noclip.
So let's make all of these off limits.
Ja, gut, mit cheats, speedrun ist ja noob.
Das ist ja kein speedrun, da kannst du einfach durchfliegen.
So now, can you beat Portal without using any portals?
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
This is surprisingly a very complicated question.
Wahrscheinlich.
Back in 2000...
Ich weiß, dass du in Portal an ganz vielen Stellen out of bounds clippen kannst und einen großen Teil der Levels umgehen kannst.
Das geht aber oftmals nur mit portals.
Also, ob man...
Schwierig zu sagen.
Es könnte auch sein, dass manche Stellen nicht gehen.
Aber mal gucken.
Es gibt doch ein Tutorial.
Wahrscheinlich kommst du aus dem Tutorial nicht raus ohne Portal oder sowas.
Egal, schauen wir mal.
Speedrunners were trying to find all sorts of glitches and gimmicks that could save time in a speedrun.
Max, brauchst du doch ein Beta-Key. Für was?
And while a ton of cool tricks were found, there was one little detail players discovered that had humorous implications for the speedrun.
That being the console command ch__createairboat.
What?
The console command would spawn an airboat in front of the player.
The airboat is a vehicle used in Half-Life 2, seen primarily in the water-hazard section of the game, where the player has to navigate through a toxic waterway.
Since the dirty water hurts the player, the airboat provides a safe way to traverse the level without taking damage from the water.
Ja gut, aber Console-Kommando kann doch nicht wirklich die Antwort sein da drauf.
In Portal, Valve just sort of copied and pasted a lot of game files from Half-Life 2.
In fact, at its core, both Portal and Team Fortress 2 are basically mods of Half-Life 2.
Ja, das wissen wir.
As a result of this, some Half-Life 2 assets, like the airboat, are buried deep in the Portal's game files.
Ach, das geht ohne Cheats!
Wirklich? Aber wie machst du denn die Konsole? Musst du nicht...
Okay, man könnte jetzt schon sagen, Konsolen-Commands generell...
Äh...
Ist schon grenzwertig, oder?
Just be a fun fact, things start getting interesting when we realize that the console command ch__createairboat is not protected by SV-Cheats.
That's right, the ability to summon an airboat at will is not a cheat command.
By modern day standards, this console command is obviously not allowed in speedruns.
But back around 2010, people were a bit more curious.
Speedrunners discovered theoretical skips with airboats that could save a ton of time.
And technically, you didn't have to turn on cheats.
So surely these skips could be used in speedruns, right?
A very skilled Portal speedrunner named DemonStrait would respond to these airboat shenanigans in a video titled Portal OMG Best Video Ever.
Bester Titel!
Oh my god! I just got the greatest idea! Check this s***, bro! Check it out! Watch this s***! Watch this s***!
Warum ist der gerade so am eskalieren?
Alter, der ist ja voll, der ist ja, der Gachi bastelt ja richtig hier gerade im Hintergrund aus.
Demonstrate jokingly says,
Oh mein Gott, ich sollte einen Airboat-Speedrun machen.
Na gut, fast sieben Jahre später, das ist genau das, was Speedrunner ausgesprochen haben.
Airboat-Percent oder was?
Airboat-Percent ist eine Kategorie von Portal-Speedrun, die das Spiel mit nur Airboats verwendet.
Das Scheiße, das gibt es wirklich.
Du bist nicht sogar ermöglicht, Portale zu benutzen.
In Wahrheit, du bekommst niemals den Portal-Gun.
Das fragt die Frage, wie sind Airboats so mächtig, dass sie dir den Portal-Speedrun ohne Portale schießen lassen lassen?
Ironically, the Airboats intended purpose, being able to navigate acid or dirty water, cannot be used in Portal.
As for some reason, the player will still take damage in the Airboat when driving on acid.
So most of the boats usefulness comes in two glitches, Airboat-Clipping and Airboat-Boosting.
Airboat-Clipping gives us the ability to clip through walls.
Since the Airboat is a vehicle, entering the Airboat will always put us in the driver's seat,
near the front of the Airboat.
However, the hitbox to enter the Airboat is quite large, extending all the way around the Airboat.
This means that if the player can enter the back of the Airboat, they will always pop out at the front.
With this in mind, a well-placed Airboat puts the back of the Airboat on one side of the wall
and the front of the Airboat on the other side of the wall.
By entering the back of the Airboat, the player will instantly teleport to the driver's seat,
and effectively clip through the wall.
Using Airboat-Clipping, we can clip through almost every obstacle in Portal.
We can skip chambers by clipping through doors.
We can clip through walls to land out of bounds.
We can even get back in bounds by using Airboats.
Airboat-Clipping can overcome most challenges in the game, but there are some exceptions.
For example, this chamber is normally solved by gaining momentum with Portals.
Clipping through walls won't help us out here.
So we need to utilize a different Airboat glitch.
That being Airboat-Boosting.
Airboat-Boosting is a possible glitch that works by spawning multiple Airboats in the same spot.
When spawning an Airboat, the game doesn't do any collision checks,
so spawning two Airboats in the same place will result in them completely overlapping.
However, the game does not like it when physics objects overlap.
um das zu lösen, drückt das Spiel Objekte, die überlappen, was bedeutet, dass die Objekte
eine reiche Anzahl an Geschwindigkeit geben werden und sich von einander entlasten.
Wir können diese Mechanik verletzen, indem wir eine Menge Objekte in dem selben Spot spawnen
und der unabhängige Druck erfolgt mehrere Male, resultierend in einem super schnellen Projektil.
Wenn das richtig gemacht wird, schafft das essentiell ein Luftwaffe-Missil, welches
die Spieler normalerweise auf den Eindruck tötet, aber wenn der Spieler an der richtigen Zeit springt,
kann er stattdessen vom Luftwaffe verletzt werden.
Das ist das Luftwaffe-Modul.
Das ist ein bisschen wie in Press of the Wild, dieses Boosten mit dem Static-Modul.
Kennt ihr das?
Wo die sich an Bäumen und Kisten quer über die Map schießen?
Das Boosting ist absurdlich mächtig, da es verwendet werden kann, um fast alle horizontalen
Flächen im Spiel zu klären und es kann auch nach oben geblieben werden, um eine deutliche Höhe zu erhöhen.
Um Luftwaffe-Booste stetig zu erzeugen, verbinden die Speedrunner ihre Maus-Wheel, um ein Luftwaffe-Modul zu spawnen,
da jeder Tick in einem Maus-Scroll einen Luftwaffe-Modul zu erzeugen.
So kann ein voller Scroll 5 bis 10 Luftwaffe erzeugen.
Und um uns alle abzutopfen...
Das ist ja fast ein bisschen wie in Overwatch, wo man am Anfang auch leicht, leicht klitschen konnte.
Mit Lucio-Jump auf Maus-Wheel.
... gibt es keine Grenzen, wie viele Luftwaffe erzeugt werden können.
Wenn dein Maus scrollt, werden Luftwaffe weiterhin erzeugt werden.
Es wird nur aufhören, wenn das Spiel letztendlich zerstört wird, weil der Entity überladet wird.
Hier ist eine kurze Demonstration davon, mit einem frischen Schuss.
Das brennt sich gleich durch, ey.
Was für eine geile Idee.
Das ist ja die Big Brain Idee.
Beste.
Oh man.
Ich hab die gleiche Maus auf der Arbeit und da nerv ich manchmal schon Leute, indem ich mein Mausrad immer mit dem Finger mache.
Also Lager raus und dann zzzz.
Oh man.
For some reason.
This can save one to two seconds in every chamber that has an elevator.
In Chamber 1, the player can precisely place an airboat to balance on a glass seam and then drive through the glass with the airboat.
They can then clip through another door to enter the elevator and finish out the chamber.
These first two chambers are an explosive chamber.
They give an explosive start to the speedrun and give a great look for what's to come.
In Chamber 8, the player can immediately airboat boost from the start of the level and flink perfectly into the end elevator.
In Chamber 11, the player can clip out of the...
Sieht aus als kackt der erstmal 20 Speedboats aus.
...initial section by placing an airboat in the wall and then climbing on another airboat to get into the driver's seat.
Then, the player can place an airboat in the chamber wall,
where they can drive on top of the airboat.
They can also move the chamber in out-of-bounds space,
before clipping back inbounds to enter Chamber 12.
In Chamber 12, the player can do airboat boosts to get high to reach the top of the level
and then can finish the chamber with a clip through the ending door.
In Chamber 15, the player normally has to use portals to solve an orb puzzle,
which activates moving platforms to get through this acid corridor.
However, with airboats, players can either clip through the upper wall
and navigate the section out of bounds,
or they can spawn a ton of airboats to clog the acid
and cross the obstacle with an airboat bridge.
A great example of thinking with airboats.
Du musst aber trotzdem wahrscheinlich noch ganz schön üben, dass das funktioniert.
Chamber 17 is one of the most well-known levels in the game,
as the player is introduced to the Companion Cube
and later has to incinerate the cube to progress.
But with the power of airboats, we can save the Companion Cube.
The player can clip through the glass at the start of the chamber.
and then line up a precise airboat over the ending door.
This airboat will land out of bounds,
but the player can then drive the airboat back in bounds to finish out the chamber.
The ending of Chamber 18 is intended to test a player's reaction time with the portal gun,
as they have to land portal shots on these platforms while maintaining their vertical momentum.
However, with airboats, the player can perform a massive airboat boost to clear the entire chamber.
Of course, there are so many cool levels,
and strategies in the speedrun,
so I would recommend watching the world record for the airboat percent speedrun,
which is linked in the description below.
Airboats shouldn't even be in Portal,
but because they lacked sheet protection,
they ended up becoming one of Portals biggest inside jokes,
and eventually created one of Portals most creative speedrun castles.
Thanks for watching and I hope you have a great day.
Verland
Bein
B
Mo
Z
retrofit options if you already have some existing blinds already also ich habe in der tat eine
überlegen irgendwo noch schon los ich glaube nicht ist komplett sinnlos für mich das ist
from sunsa and what's cool about this is that it's a smart wand so ich hatte im bad früher
welche habe ich nicht mehr easy install they say it takes about two minutes but you do have
to add a extra little piece with 3m tape okay da ist ein motor drin der das ding dann für dich
dreht oder was it took me a total nicht im bad im bad im bett so i don't know if i'm slow or
something configuring it was pretty simple in the app it walks you through the steps to set
the blinds to the closed and open position you probably notice that it's slightly thicker than
your normal blind one because if it's for double a batteries in here and
they can last about a year for power result da bin ich gespannt ob das wirklich ein jahr hält
je nachdem wie oft du brauchst also diese diese das habe ich schon gemerkt zeitangaben was smart
home gadgets ist äußerst fragwürdig immer so few other power options you can plug it in to the
wall or you can plug it into a solar panel so it won't run out of battery wenn du wach werden willst
machst du damit morgens eine jalousie laufen and wifi is built into this so you don't need an extra
also works with your google and amazon voice assistance naja so richtig überzeugt bin ich
nicht so richtig überzeugt schon wieder eine eigene app please integriert euch doch in irgendwas
gescheites und nicht alle immer eine eigene app und dann in the evening it closes at sunset for
some extra privacy it's still in pre-order on indiegogo but it should be available soon and
links to everything will be found in the description and links to everything will be found in the description
was war is nicht so richtig überzeugt bin ich nicht davon switch bor dapd ist cool
also switch bot nicht das ding der der eigentliche der eigentliche
switch bot der ist richtig cool swearchplonschalter
der eigentliche switch bot da habe ich auch zwei stück von der ist wirklich cool
ja guck seht ihr das das ist ein schalter um
schalter zu schalten das ist wenn du sachen hast die sich nicht automatisieren lassen und nach wie
vor knöpfe brauchst zum drücken ist das ding richtig cool du kannst den knopf quasi drücken
lassen ohne das gerät zu automatisieren weil wir jetzt einen wlan-knopf fast meine katze
mit wegrennen wenn das darum das ist eine coole sache der schalter leute kekona schalter
und wer sich jetzt fragt wie kriegt man den schalter wieder umgeschaltet ganz einfach es
gibt so ein gummi ist kein gummi band ja also ein band mit kleber das machst du an den schalter dran
und dann schaltet der schalter einfach in die andere richtung zieht es wieder raus
also das ist wirklich cooles produkt da habe ich sage ich auch zwei stück von
switch
boxe port city
ja es auf jeden fall nice aber dings steuerung für einen rollladen und fünf vorhang sind die
dinge sieg wie fähig nee das ist wifi
ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher ob die bluetooth oder wifi sind aber wifi
alles braucht eine eigene das ist ja eine sache die mich an smart home extrem abfuckt alles hat
eine eigene app
Das Beste ist, wenn die eine eigene App haben für die Noobs, die es gerne einfach einschalten würden und benutzen,
aber zusätzlich noch die Möglichkeiten haben, in irgendeiner Art und Weise sich zu integrieren.
MQTT ist am einfachsten, das können die meisten Dinger,
aber es können auch einfach normale Get-Requests sein, wenn das Ding im WLAN hängt.
Das ist mir egal, Hauptsache man kann es irgendwie ansprechen.
Entwickelt doch eine App, die andere Apps automatisiert.
Für genau sowas ist ja sowas wie Home Assistant oder Open Hub oder IO Broker oder sowas da.
Für genau solche Dinger, dafür gibt es das ja.
Also wenn du es mit deinem Voice Assistant oder SmartThings verbinden willst,
brauchst du das SwitchBot Hub Mini.
Die meisten Leute werden es wahrscheinlich auf einem Fenster benutzen,
aber wir benutzen es tatsächlich in einem Türraum,
weil in unserem Theaterraum es ein bisschen leuchtend wird während des Tages mit einem Projektor.
Also haben wir es mit einigen Körnern in den Türraum geschlossen und es ist ziemlich toll.
Also jetzt, wenn wir einen Film während des Tages sehen,
schluckt die Automation komplett den Raum.
Die nächsten Lösungen sind für diejenigen, die es nicht mögen,
deine Existenz zu verändern.
Oder wenn du in ein neues Haus wechselst.
Das sind die Ikea Motorized Roll-Anschläge.
Genug Platz und ein Anschluss für den Motor dran.
Ich gucke immer so überrascht.
Wenn es Ikea ist,
wenn es Ikea ist, dann ist es wahrscheinlich ZigBee, oder?
...Manuals with it.
Six.
All I wanted to do was set the max length.
And it was buried in a tiny paragraph in one of the manuals.
So let me save you some time.
To set the max length, you just double-press the top or bottom button for power.
It uses a rechargeable battery that's supposed to last about four to six months.
You can also get a spare rechargeable battery for...
Das ist zu wenig.
Also alles unter einem Jahr ist zu wenig.
Ich gehe sogar so weit,
du brauchst...
Also, es wäre schön, wenn der Kram zwei Jahre hält.
Weil, es geht ja nicht um ein Gerät.
Du hast dir dein Haus damit ausgestattet.
Und wenn du dein Haus damit ausgestattet hast,
bist du ja im Endeffekt, wenn du ganz viel...
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt ganz viele Geräte,
die sind wireless und halten alles...
Die Batterie dort hält bei allen nur vier bis fünf Monate.
Wenn ihr wirklich einiges an Geräten dabei habt,
seid ihr ja wöchentlich, wenn nicht täglich, an Batterien tauschen.
Wird ja nicht alles gleichzeitig leer.
Deswegen, der Kram sollte schon ein Jahr, besser zwei Jahre halten.
Oder, es bräuchte eine Möglichkeit, dass ich irgendwie Strom anschließe.
Das wäre auch noch eine Option, wenn man oben einen Stromanschluss hat.
...figured sizes.
If you mount it on the inside, there may be some big gaps on the side.
Or, you could mount it on the outside, like I did in the other room,
to block the light a little bit better.
It uses Zigbee, so you'll need a hub to connect it to the internet.
Zigbee!
And I have mine connected directly to smart things.
Ich habe ja mittlerweile alles an Protokollen da.
Z-Waves, Zigbee, WiFi, Bluetooth, alles, alles am Start.
Elektrosmog is real im Haus, ja.
...a couple of these IKEA shades in my office.
And since I'm not in there all the time, I'm using a motion sensor to automate them.
So, if I'm in the room, and it's nice outside, so it's not too hot,
then the shades will open up during the day.
Next is the Lutron Serena shades, which work similar to IKEA,
but they're much higher quality, with a bigger price tag.
LoRa hab ich auch, ja, genau.
Installing these was very similar to IKEA.
You mount a couple of brackets inside or outside your window frame,
but they're custom made to fit your window frame.
Ich hab tatsächlich noch RF, äh, alter Funk-Kram, was war das?
RF4, RF, keine Ahnung, die, die, ähm, die Rollläden sind noch ganz old school Funk.
RF433, genau, ja.
Die sind, die hab ich ja auch noch.
Also, wie gesagt, also, hier ist alles voll mit, äh...
...Window, exactly.
So, it won't let in as much light on the sides,
which makes it perfect for...
...the theater room, because it's gonna black out the room even more.
Configuring the Lutron shades is much easier than IKEA,
since they're custom made to fit your window,
and they come pre-programmed to extend the right length.
When it comes to power, you have two options when you're buying them.
You can use disposable batteries,
or you can upgrade to plug it into the wall.
I chose plugging it into the wall,
even though there's a long cord and it's difficult to hide.
I'd rather do that than replace batteries.
This is where IKEA and...
Das triggert schon wieder einige Leute.
Mich persönlich würd's jetzt nicht sonderlich stören,
so was hier am Fenster zu haben,
aber ich weiß, es triggert einige Leute,
und wollen das auf partout nicht haben.
My opinion is actually better,
because they have rechargeable batteries,
making it more convenient.
I've shown you how loud all the other blinds and shades are,
and Lutron is by far the most silent.
Die Lautstärke für die 10 Sekunden wäre mir jetzt nicht so wichtig.
I wanted to put these in my bedroom,
so I could automate them to wake me up in the morning.
And they're a great fit for this,
because they're so quiet,
so I'm not gonna wake up from the sound of the shades,
instead from the light shining through the window.
I love this automation,
and I'm pretty sure my wife does, too.
It works out of the box with the Pico remotes,
which are super convenient,
and if you want to connect it to your other smart home devices,
you'll need the Lutron Caseta Smart Bridge.
But it's the same bridge that works with their smart switches,
so you might already have one.
These also come in wood blinds,
if you prefer that.
These products also come in wood blinds,
These products are just what I'm using in my house.
Of course, there are more advanced solutions out there,
and you could probably even save some money
doing that as well.
But I like these options,
since they're so easy to install and set up.
Make sure to hit that subscribe button
to see more automation ideas with
smart shakes and other tech around the house.
to see more automation ideas with smart shakes and other tech around the house.
Excellent.
Okay, wollen wir cringen?
Ich will eigentlich nicht.
Oh nein, nein!
Ich hab's schon gesehen, das wird schlimm.
Also wenn er das erste Bild ist, wird's schlimm.
Der alte Zerstörer.
Der alte Zerstörer ist am Start.
Hey ihr alten Zerstörer.
Please, nein!
Hör auf!
Hey ihr alten Zerstörer.
Was geht Gänge, Jonas hier am Start für euch.
Gibt's... Ich hab sogar letztens
einen Wecker gesehen. Der zerspringt mich
nur in Teile. Der schießt
irgendwas in die Luft.
Was quer durchs Zimmer fliegt. Du musst es
erst suchen. Das ist ne geile
Taktik. Weiß ich... Warte mal.
Wecker
zerspringen beim Klingeln.
Der Wecklauf... Moment.
Das...
Der schießt irgend so ne Drohne.
Der schießt so ein Teil ab
und das fliegt irgendwo im Raum hin
und das musst du dann erst wieder reinstecken,
dass es aufhört zu klingeln.
Das find ich mega geil.
Ich hab gedacht, die haben auch ein Video zu haben.
Oh, billiges
China-Kram. Aber die Idee
find ich halt geil.
Es klingelt erst mal...
quer durch den Raum.
Ja, gibt schon coole Ideen. Okay, okay.
Eine Runde Cringe.
Aus dem Weg und elf noch richtig
laissez-faire auf Internet
ausgeschrieben. Ich mein, ich glaub...
Das sind halt irgendwelche Leute, die von Internet-Memes
und Kultur...
Keine Ahnung. Okay, von Kultur zu sprechen, ist das
vielleicht ein bisschen hochtrabend, aber
die keine Ahnung haben, was Sache ist.
Boah.
CDU Connect ist so schlecht, dass es
diverse Artikel gibt, die sich darüber lustig
machen. Aber schauen wir uns das Ganze
doch einfach mal genauer an.
Analysieren wir diesen Albtraum einer
Social-Media-Kampagne mal im Detail.
Two, one, go!
Ganz kurz, bevor es losgeht. Bald kommt
endlich neuer Stuff bei Culture Culture.
Für alle, die es noch nicht kennen, wir designen seit
Jahren eigene Prints und produzieren
jetzt auch seit einiger Zeit komplett... Socken!
Endlich! Endlich Dingssocken!
Äh... Wie heißt da
der andere Channel von ihm nochmal?
Ich vergess immer.
Socken.
Ja, stimmt. War das Simplicissimus?
Ich wollte schon immer mal Socken.
Vox hat eine spannende Glad-You-Asked-Episode
über Memes, Politik und Desinformation
und der Top-Kommensalist.
Er sagt, commercially producing
Memes is like trying to be cool.
If you're trying, you're not.
Da würden wir komplett zustimmen. Vielleicht ist das der Grund,
warum mir das hier
den Willen zu leben raubt.
Ich meine, was soll das? Ist das ein lustiger
Reminder, dass man den lustigen
Segway-Tempo-Limit-Vergleich gedroht hat?
Wollte ich grad sagen. Ich verstehe den
Witz da dran gar nicht.
Die Kommentare mal für sich sprechen. Egal, welchen Post
ich von euch sehe, denke ich mir, wie unlustig man
sein kann. Auf dem Segway durch die Gegend zu fahren...
Ich glaube, Philipp Amthor hat sich
das zur Aufgabe gemacht, dass man möglichst
unlustig... Wobei ich den Kerl, also
ich würde nicht sagen mag,
ja, der hat schon
irgendwas. Also der nimmt das wenigstens...
Der spielt den Scheiß wenigstens mit.
Das macht ihn mir in gewisser
Art doch sympathisch, ja.
Der kennt den Mist.
Und er macht mit.
Also,
ja, so schlimm finde ich den gar nicht.
Mal halb so peinlich wie
euer Content. Wird da Herrn Maaßen
in Thüringen zugezwinkert?
Oder der AfD? Oder den
Jugendlichen?
Exquisite Musik im Hintergrund, Leute.
CDU-Connect bringt den Jugendlichen aber nicht nur
spielerisch-politische Haltung näher,
wie Tempo-Limit-Gleich-Lahm.
Nein, man drückt der Konkurrenz auch
zielgruppengerechte, dynamische
Wort-Bild-Collagen rein.
So weit in der Geschichte
Zeug, dass ich das nicht mehr weiß.
Erstmal
Wahnsinn, wie cool und lässig Armin
da grinst. Also, perfekt gewählter
Ausschnitt. Für mich aber am herrlichsten
der... Das wirkt eher so, als du
nach dem Motto, ich hab keine Ahnung,
was ich sagen soll. Oder, was soll es
das... Was soll es das... Ja, ich weiß nicht.
Omega-unangenehme Luftanhalter
am Ende.
Sagt der noch was? Sagt der nichts mehr?
Armin, was
ist? Spuck's aus.
Aber kaum ein Meme von CDU-Connect
demonstriert, wie sehr man
das Medium nicht verstanden hat.
Oh, das ist ja wirklich hart.
Boah, cringe, Alter.
Das ist doch nicht mal lustig, das ist einfach
dumm. Das ist nicht
mal lustig, das ist...
Das ist, man nimmt
irgendein Bild, schreibt irgendeinen Text drüber
und... Hä?
Das sind doch nicht mal
Boomer-Memes, das sind Gag, das sind
einfach zusammenhanglose
Dinger.
Wie ich, wenn ich mich sorgfältig an
die Briefwahl-Anleitung gehalten und
Rot und Blau nicht durcheinander gebracht habe.
Hä?
Was hat das damit zu tun?
Oh, oh, White-Power-Verschwörungstheorien
jetzt gleich wieder. Ich seh's schon, komm.
Wo ist hier der Witz?
Wo? Ja, genau das frage ich mich auch.
Wo ist der Witz? Wo ist er?
Wo? Warum sieht das aus
wie ein Meme, ist aber eine Briefwahl-Anleitung.
Egal, hier nochmal eine verspätete
Portion Giga-Cringe zur EM.
Oh, ist das
schlecht.
Am 11. Juli...
Genau, wir sind heiß und drücken
unseren Jungs die Daumen.
Was wollen die überhaupt?
Was ist da gerade passiert?
Diese Ballübergaben, diese Sprüche.
Ich meine, warum postet man sowas
als CDU? Den Clip hätte ich so
tief in der Erde vergraben und einfach
gebetet, dass er niemals von irgendwem
gefunden wird.
Vielleicht missverstehen
wir das aber auch.
Und das ist die eigentliche Taktik.
Quasi so uncool
und cringe und
langweilig und blöd rüberzukommen,
dass die Leute gerade
deswegen da...
Ich weiß nicht, ob das die Taktik ist.
...Tagswahl, hart kickt.
Das wäre richtig Elevenhead.
Kickt wegen Fußball.
So, aber atmen wir einmal
alle tief durch, erholen wir uns von dem,
was wir uns hier gerade angetan haben.
Das wirkt ein bisschen...
Ja, ey, das wirkt ein bisschen so,
wie wenn früher
irgendwelche Unternehmen Werbung gemacht haben
für die junge Generation.
Wo man dann irgendwelche Jugendsprache
reingebaut hat, die seit 10 Jahren nicht mehr
aktuell ist.
Das ist so, wie wenn ich ein Video
machen würde für die junge
Generation und quasi
laufend sagen würde, keine Ahnung,
krass und alter
und sonst was. So das, was man in meiner
Zeit gesagt hat.
Ja, dabei
werden heute ganz andere
Dinger erzählt.
Heute wird gesagt, fühl ich Digger.
... die U-Connect-App
und den TikTok-Account angeguckt,
den erspare ich euch einfach mal.
Scherz, denn CDU-Connect hat den
hippsten und coolsten Politiker ihrer Partei
ausgepackt, den Mitte-60-Jährigen
Philipp Amthor.
Hey, ihr alten Zerstörer.
Wenn ihr nicht nur auf die richtigen Sachschäden zur Bundestagswahl
setzen wollt, sondern auch auf
ondischabernackt beim Wahlkampf...
Ich finde, ohne Scheiß,
ich finde an dem cool, dass der den Scheiß irgendwie mitmacht.
Der weiß, es machen sich da alle über ihn
lustig und sonst wie, aber der macht mit.
Ähm...
Welche Taktik dahinter steckt, keine Ahnung.
Jetzt Connect-Untersteller.
Auch hier verstehe ich nicht, was mir hier gesagt wird.
Ja, das fällt gut, das habe ich noch nie verstanden.
Wenn ihr nicht nur auf die richtigen Sachthemen setzen wollt,
sondern auch auf
ordentlich schabernackt beim Wahlkampf...
Der, das ist jetzt einfach,
dass er seine Amthor-Memes selber memet,
was irgendwie merkwürdig ist,
weil, egal.
Was? Also bei CDU-Connect
gibt es die richtigen Sachthemen
und ordentlich schabernackt?
Ich verstehe es einfach nicht.
Was ist hier die Message?
Wie verkauft?
Kann ein 30-sekündiges TikTok sein?
Soll das sein, wir besprechen echte Themen,
aber erlauben uns auch mal einen Spaß?
Ist das...
Mal einen Schritt zurück.
CDU-Connect kommuniziert
für mich vor allem zwei Dinge.
Erstens, ein völliges Unverständnis
für das Internet.
Obwohl hinter CDU-Connect ein junges Team steckt.
Ja, das hast du aber bei vielen.
Also wie gesagt,
guckt euch an, wenn Unternehmen Werbung für junge Leute machen.
Das ist auch immer total
vorbei.
Das funktioniert ja einfach überhaupt nicht.
Die Accounts haben jeweils keine 10.000.
Oder man sieht das ja sogar,
man muss ja gar nicht so weit gehen und sagen,
wenn Unternehmen Werbung machen für junge Leute,
es reicht schon, wenn
jemand Werbung macht,
der eigentlich Ahnung hat.
Guckt euch Spielehersteller an,
guckt euch Hardwarehersteller an und sowas.
Die sollten ja eigentlich vom aktuellen Thema
ein bisschen mehr Ahnung haben.
Aber sogar da ist es teilweise so
unverständlich,
was die,
was die wollen von einem.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern,
dass die,
ich glaube bei Ghostreken
war das glaube ich,
das war ein Video plus zwei Tweets,
wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es Ghostreken,
es können auch Sniper Elite oder irgendwas gewesen sein,
ich weiß nicht mehr.
Irgendwas, wo ich mal ein bisschen Game Sellout gemacht habe
vor ein paar Jahren.
Und mit dem Video und so alles vollkommen okay.
Aber ich sollte dann zwei Tweets
machen mit irgendwelchen
komischen Hashtags,
die keine Sau verwendet.
Also,
warum?
Warum soll ich solche dummen Hashtags verwenden?
Wo ist der Sinn davon?
Mal ganz davon abgesehen,
dass jeder auch jeder zwei Kilometer
gegen den Wind sieht,
dass ich null meine persönliche Sache
in den Tweet gesteckt habe,
sondern im Prinzip einfach dadurch nur
runtergeschrieben habe,
was ihr haben wollt.
Das gucken sich dann 20 Leute an,
haben keinen Bock drauf.
Das ist komisch.
Also,
ich bin ein Follower
und unter jedem Post wird die Partei nur gedisst.
Und dann zweitens so eine Art,
so Pseudo-Selbstironische-Selbsteingeständnisse zu machen.
Diese Karriere, Ronny.
Ja, wir sind eine Partei voller alter Menschen,
die Politik macht,
von der sich viele junge Menschen nicht abgeholt fühlen.
Und wir haben zum Beispiel jahrzehntelang
die Digitalisierung verpennt.
Haha, aber guckt mal,
wir machen jetzt einen Floppy-Disc.
Moment, Moment.
Wir haben nicht nur die Digitalisierung verpennt,
wir haben den Internetausbau
die letzten 20 Jahren,
25 Jahren komplett verpennt.
Joke.
Mit unserem Wahlkampfbegriff
Modernisierungsjahrzehnt.
Und ja, es wird besser,
die letzten Jahre,
aber besser reicht nicht.
Weil wie holt man auf,
nicht indem man das macht,
was andere vor 15 Jahren gemacht haben,
sondern man holt auf,
indem man besser und schneller ist als die anderen.
Das einzige, was jetzt passiert ist,
dass wir Sachen machen,
die andere vor 10, 15 Jahren schon gemacht haben
oder zumindest angeleiert haben
und die jetzt quasi schon die Ergebnisse davon haben.
Das machen wir jetzt auch.
Aber die sind mit noch höherem Tempo vorneweg.
Also das Einzige, was wir jetzt aktuell machen,
ist, wir holen nicht auf.
Wir fallen nur langsamer zurück.
Also eigentlich bescheuert.
Der Fairness halber, andere Parteien haben auch Meme-Pages,
nicht immer offiziell von der Partei,
aber die sind alle debunked durch mal mehr,
mal weniger, latent, unangenehm.
Also ich finde ganz persönlich...
Moment, Moment.
Was zum? Was?
Sexy Söder.
Wirklich. Ernsthaft.
Ich finde ganz persönlich Politik und politische Ansichten
so verkürzt eh ein bisschen schwierig.
Also das Problem habe ich auch immer mit so Kampf-Tweets auf Twitter.
Naja, egal, was diesen Wahlkampf noch kommt,
CDU-Connect wird schwer zu toppen.
Wenn ihr euch mal ernsthafter mit Memes und Politik befassen wollt,
das Video von VOX und einige Artikel
haben wir euch in der Beschreibung verlinkt.
Ansonsten...
Okay, dazu kann ich nur sagen, was im Chat gerade gepostet wurde.
Ist immer lustig, sich vom Twitter-Account,
Twitter-Account-Tagesschau vorzuhalten.
Man muss doch nicht mal 20 Jahre gucken.
2018, bis Ende 2018, hat 50 MBit für jeden Haushalt.
Wir sind übrigens bis 2020 auch führend,
was digitale Behörden und sowas angeht.
Wurde auch gesagt, noch 2016, glaube ich.
Wir sollen jetzt, und das können wir uns in zwei Jahren mal angucken,
was daraus geworden ist,
ja der Leitmarkt für Computerspiele werden.
Da wird einfach Bullshit erzählt,
ohne jeglichen Sinn und Verstand.
Weil man sich denkt, das interessiert doch dann eh keinen mehr.
Wie der Kanal heißt, Two Bored Guys.
So, jetzt wurde irgendwelche TikTok.
Leute, ich habe noch nie TikTok aufgemacht.
Ist das Rewe Karriere?
TikTok.
Premiere, ich habe noch nie TikTok geöffnet.
Jetzt wird es schlimm.
Jetzt ist das Tor zur Unterwelt.
Ach stimmt, TikTok hat ja keine Lautstärkeregelung.
Habe ich ja ganz vergessen.
Okay, was ist da?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh ne, das kann man ja auch groß machen.
Hör mal auf.
Hör mir auf, Alter.
Das ist ja schlimm.
Was schreiben denn Leute so auf TikTok?
Ach so, stimmt.
Ich vergaß mal, keine TikTok.
Telefonnummer.
Weiter mit.
Fake Apple Profil oder so.
Vergessen, man muss sich dafür anmelden.
Das ist doch eben.
So.
Armbrust, Flying
Browser-Tipps
Lasst uns mal eben Venus terraformen
Alles klar, kommen wir terraformen die Venus
Ich kenn das Video schon, das war eigentlich nicht schlecht
Aber ihr müsst mal drauf achten
Am Anfang sagen die so nach dem Motto
Es könnte so einfach sein, sinngemäß
Und dann erzählen sie
Zwölf Minuten, dass es eigentlich nicht möglich ist
Das ist schmerzhaft, ja
Aber richtig
Huge
Huge pain
Bisschen leise, hä?
Früher oder später
Wird das vielleicht überlebensnotwendig sein
Die meisten denken dabei
Sofort an den Mars
Ein kleiner, giftiger und energie...
Was ich auch immer lustig finde
Wir machen uns Gedanken über Terraforming
So nach dem Motto
Wir terraformen
Quasi die Venus, den Mars
Zur Erde, aber wir sind noch nicht mal
In der Lage
Unsere Erde auch nur ansatzweise
Zu terraformen
Zu irgendwas, was nicht
Probleme macht
In den nächsten Jahren, ja
Also da hab ich so meine Zweifel
Ob wir dann einfach mal nehmen
Bei kurz nachher Planet Terraform
Aber gut
Denen geht es ja auch nicht darum
Dass wir das jetzt gleich machen
Sondern in Zukunft
...gut genug um eine Kolonie deprimierter Menschen
In unterirdischen Städten einzupferchen
Warum aber nicht ambitionierter denken
Was wenn wir stattdessen die Venus besiedeln
Einen der lebensfeindlichsten und tödlichsten
Nee, nee, wir machen das gerade so, dass wir die Venus besiedeln
Einen der lebensfeindlichsten und tödlichsten Menschen in der Welt
Nee, nee, wir machen das gerade umgedreht
Wir machen die Erde zur Venus
Das geht doch auch, da müssen wir nicht die Venus besiedeln
...orten in unserem Sonnensystem
Und zwar nicht mit luftigen Wolkenstädten
Sondern indem wir sie in eine echte zweite Erde verwandeln
Das geht einfacher als du denkst
Einfach, verachtet mal drauf
Das Intro hat mich das letzte Mal auch ein bisschen ausgelöst
Ja, also
Es geht einfacher als du denkst
Und jetzt zeigen sie uns zwölf Minuten lang
Dass es eigentlich nicht möglich ist
Mit einer Oberflächentemperatur
Von 460 Grad Celsius
Ist die Erde zu Venus
Und Venus ist bei weitem der heißeste Planet
In unserem Sonnensystem
Da schmilzt sogar Blei
Diese Hitze liegt am extremen Treibhauseffekt
CO2 fängt Hitze ein
Selbst der CO2-Anstieg von 0,03%
Auf 0,04% in der Erdatmosphäre
Ist genug, dass sich unser Planet derzeit aufheizt
Und Venus-Atmosphäre besteht zu 97% aus CO2
Ich dachte, die Sonne ist der heißeste Planet
Die Sonne ist kein Planet
Die Sonne ist die Venus-Atmosphäre
93 Mal so dicht wie die der Erde
Auf ihrer Oberfläche zu stehen
Wäre also etwa so wie 900 Meter tief
In den Ozean zu tauchen
Unter dem Druck würdest du so stark sterben
Da hab ich jetzt nicht mit gerechnet
In den Ozean zu tauchen
Unter dem Druck würdest du so stark sterben
Normalerweise haben die immer
So eine verträgliche Animation
Aber warum lohnt es sich trotzdem?
Zuerst einmal hat die Venus-Atmosphäre
Etwa die gleiche Größe wie die Erde
Und daher rund 90% ihrer Schwerkraft
Schwerkraft ist ein großes Problem
Beim Besiedeln des Sonnensystems
Aber die Venus hat kein Magnetfeld, oder?
Hat die Venus ein Magnetfeld?
Sie hat der Aufenthalt an Orten mit kleiner Anziehung
Ziemlich sicher negative Auswirkungen auf die Gesundheit
Mit ihrer Größe könnte die Venus außerdem ein neues Zuhause
Für Milliarden Menschen und Billionen Menschen
Weil gerade wenn wir noch näher an der Sonne dran sind
Ist so ein Magnetfeld gar nicht so groß wie die Erde
Und die Erde ist eine sehr, sehr große Welt
Und die Erde ist gar nicht mal verkehrt
Meeren, üppigen Wäldern und wunderbar blauem Himmel
Auf einer richtig Terra-geformten Venus
Könnte das Leben so schön wie hier auf der Erde sein
Auf die Stelle können wir die Venus nicht Terra-formen
Aber mit ordentlich Ehrgeiz könnten unsere Nachfahren es schaffen
Es würde zwar ein paar Generationen dauern
Und wäre eine riesige Herausforderung
So wie der Bau der großen Pyramiden zum Beispiel
Es wäre aber nicht das erste Mal, dass Menschen Projekte angefangen haben
Die länger als ein Menschenleben dauern
Das ist eine große Herausforderung
Das stimmt
Also, los
Da müsste man aber ein bisschen vorausschauend denken
Ich hab das Gefühl, das haben wir verloren
Das ist grad nicht angesagt
Unterkühlen
Und dazu müssen wir die Gase entfernen
Aus denen die extrem dichte Atmosphäre besteht
Wie gesagt, Gase hat's jede Menge
Etwa 465 Millionen Milliarden Tonnen
Ganz einfach
Selbst geflashten Staubsauger
Über die Venus fahren lassen
Custom-Firmware
Und dann können wir die Venus fahren lassen
Es gibt mehrere Möglichkeiten
Riesige Sonnenkollektoren zum Beispiel
Die eine Reihe von Laserstrahlen antreiben
Die wiederum die Atmosphäre so stark aufheizen
Dass sie ins All explodiert
Na klar, na klar
Easy, easy
Vor allem überlegt ihr mal
Also erstens, wie lange das dauert
Und was sie für eine Power bräuchten
Für diese Laser, wo kriegst du denn das her?
Viel Energie, wie die Menschheit bisher produziert hat
Und selbst dann würde es noch tausende Jahre dauern
Die Atmosphäre loszuwerden
Wir könnten die Atmosphäre auch binden
So, dass das CO2
Durch chemische Reaktionen
Verschiedene Verbindungen eingeht
Wir könnten Elemente wie Calcium
Ja, dann mach mal mit so ein paar Sonnenkollektoren
Mach da mal so einen Laserstrahl
Das stelle ich mir
äußerst schwierig vor
Magnesium auf dem Merkur abbauen
Und mittels eines elektromagnetischen Katapults
Also eines Massebeschleunigers
Zur Venus schießen
Und so Raketen auf kleineren Planeten
Chefplan schon, easy!
Die Metalle würden das CO2
Für immer zu verschiedenen Karbonaten binden
Aber die schiere Menge macht das ziemlich
Unpraktikabel
Wir bräuchten dafür hunderte Millionen
Milliarden Tonnen Material
Hunderte Millionen Milliarden
Alles klar
Das würde aber vielleicht zu lange dauern
Eine weitere verrückte Idee
Die funktionieren könnte wäre
Venus einfach in den Schatten zu stellen
Wortwörtlich
Wir könnten einen riesigen Spiegel bauen
So dass die Atmosphäre einfriert
Der fliegt weg
Der bleibt ja nicht da
Nur eine dünne Folie
Auf einer Rahmenkonstruktion
Eine große flache Oberfläche
In der Nähe der Sonne
Nur so dünn wie ein Coronavirus
Aber wie ein Sonnensegel verhalten
Und sofort verschoben werden
Deshalb ist unser Spiegel
Kein einzelnes riesiges kreisförmiges Objekt
Ich wollte gerade sagen
Warum nehmen wir nicht einfach die Venus
Weiter weg
Wenn wir schon dabei sind
Ringförmig angeordnete Spiegellamellen
Reflektieren das Sonnenlicht
Von einem Spiegelset zum nächsten
Im richtigen Winkel wird das Licht immer weiter reflektiert
Und zur Rückseite geleitet
Was die Kraft an der Vorderseite ausbalanciert
Und das ganze Konstrukt
In Position hält
So eine Infrastruktur zu positionieren
Würde ein paar Jahre dauern
Dann geht's los
Ein paar Jahre
Das ist vernachlässigbar
In den ersten paar Jahrzehnten
Kühlt die Atmosphäre langsam ab
Ist aber immer noch sehr dicht und tödlich
Dann nach etwa 60 Jahren
Ist die kritische Temperatur von 1,3
Ich guck die Videos wirklich gerne von denen
Die machen gerne solche Themen
Die Animationen sind cool
Ich find das auch immer interessant
Aber dieses Mal muss ich sagen
Gerade mit dem Intro
Das könnte einfacher sein als man denkt
Es ist halt nur 12 Minuten dann
Warum es nicht so einfach ist
Ich sag mal so
Bevor Stuttgart 21 fertig ist
Haben wir wahrscheinlich wirklich die Venus Terra formt
Flüssig und regnet herab
Konstantes Regenwetter
Unglaublichen Ausmaßes
Und das planetenweit für 30 Jahre
Druck und Temperatur
Sinken jetzt plötzlich gleichzeitig
Über fast 100 Jahre
Werden Pfützen zu Seen und Ozeanen
Die Oberflächentemperatur
Beträgt jetzt
Minus 56 Grad Celsius
Und der Druck ist nur noch etwa 7 Grad Celsius
Kurz gesagt heißt der Kanal
Bei ungemütlichen Minus 81 Grad Celsius
Gefriert das CO2 schließlich
Und aus dem Regen wird Schnee
Frostchamp
Übrig bleibt eine tiefgekühlte Venus
Bedeckt von steinhart gefrorenen Ozeanen
Und riesigen CO2 Gletschern
Die übrig gebliebene Atmosphäre
Besteht hauptsächlich aus Stickstoff
Unter etwa dem Dreifachen des Druckes
Der Erdatmosphäre
Wenn es dir nichts ausmacht zu erfrieren
Und zu ersticken
Kannst du jetzt gleich auf der Venus herumspazieren
Aber auch im gefrorenen Zustand
Ist das CO2 noch ein Problem
Wollen wir dem Planeten erst wieder auftauen
Schmilzt das CO2 Eis
Und steigt wieder in die Atmosphäre
Das müssen wir also irgendwie verhindern
Wir könnten zum Beispiel
Alles einfach mit einer billigen
Plastikisolation überziehen
Und mit gemahlenem Venusgestein
Oder jeder Menge Wasser bedecken
Einige Wissenschaftler würde es aber wohl
Ziemlich stressen unser neues Zuhause
Auf so einer Zeitbombe zu erschaffen
Ein paar schlecht getimte Vulkanausbrüche
Und jede Menge geschmolzenes CO2
Würde alles ruinieren
Eine andere offensichtliche Lösung wäre es
Das ganze CO2 Eis
Ins All zu schießen
Einen kleinen Mond daraus zu formen
Und es so für spätere Zwecke aufzubewahren
Elektromagnetik
Warum machen wir das nicht auf der Erde
Das wäre doch eine coole Sache
Wir schießen einfach das CO2
Zu einem zweiten Mond
Easy
So machen wir das
Ich melde schon mal Patent an
Katapulte sind dabei zwar effizienter als Raketen
Ah das geht nicht
Die haben keine Atmosphäre
Wir haben eine Atmosphäre
Da kannst du sowas nicht rausschießen
Trotzdem wird das dauern
Wie auch immer wir das mit der Atmosphäre machen
Damit es weiter geht
Brauchen wir auf jeden Fall Wasser
Das können wir von Eismonden gewinnen
Europa einer der Jupitermonde
Hat doppelt so viel Wasser
Wie alle Ozeane der Erde zusammen
Einen Mond einzufangen
Und durchs Sonnensystem zu transportieren
Ist aber nicht gerade ein Kinderspiel
Vielleicht wäre es also einfacher
Mit einer Armee von Drohnen
Große Eisstücke von Europa abzubrechen
Und mit weiteren elektromagnetischen Katapulten
Zur Venus zu schießen
Wie sollen die Dinger fliegen
Dabei könnten uns sogenannte Space Tethers
Ziemlich viel Aufwand und Energie sparen
Wow Slingshot
Kurz gesagt
Sind sie eine Art Schleudern
Ah yes
Das ist cool
Da braucht man ein gutes Timing
Wisst ihr woran das scheitern wird
Ich sag es euch
Es wird daran scheitern
Europa baut das Ding in Zentimeter
Und die Amis bauen das in Inches
Und dann fliegt das einfach vorbei
Venus zu katapultieren
Dort trifft das Eis wieder auf andere Space Tethers
Die es in der Atmosphäre abladen
Von wo es als Schnee hinabfällt
Im Austausch können die Venus Tethers
CO2 Eis
Und die Planeten aus Hochgeschossen wird aufnehmen
Und in die vielleicht auch sehr weit entfernte
Umlaufbahn bringen
Mit derselben Technik können wir auch
Überschüssigen Stickstoff entfernen
Und so den Druck weiter senken
Ein paar Jahrzehnte oder Jahrhunderte später
Ist auf der Venus
Ein seichter gefrorener Ozean entstanden
Ein paar hundert Meter tief
Ein krasser Unterschied zur heutigen Venus
Ein paar Kontinente
Und viele kleine Inseln haben sich gebildet
So muss ein Planet aussehen
Das ist auch das meteorische System
Bei der NASA sind ja auch keine Deppen
Jetzt beginnt die letzte und großartigste Phase
Des Terraformens
Wir sorgen dafür, dass wir die Atmosphäre atmen können
Und schließlich Leben ins Spiel bringen
Natürlich
Einfach
Kein Problem
Easy
2802 Stunden lang
Ich hoffe
Ich hoffe die machen da auch Daily Scrum
Sonst geht das ganze nämlich in die Hose
Wenn das nicht agil gemanagt wird
Einfach die Spiegel wieder entfernen
Grillen wir den halben Planeten
Selbst ohne die massive Atmosphäre
Würden die Temperaturen in unerträgliche Höhen klettern
Die einfachste Art
Einen Tag-Nacht-Zyklus hinzukriegen
Und moderate Temperaturen herzustellen
Ist ein neues Spiegelkonstrukt
Na klar
Mit dem wir die Kontinente beleuchten
Und die gefrorenen Ozeane
Das macht jetzt glaube ich die Flat Earth Leute
Ein bisschen nervös sowas
Schmelzen können
Dadurch haben wir die komplette Kontrolle darüber
Flat Venus kommt dann als nächstes
Flat Earth ist aus
Flat Venus
Die Atmosphäre besteht jetzt
Hauptsächlich aus Stickstoff
Und enthält nahezu gar keinen Sauerstoff
Als erstes ziehen also
Aberbillionen Cyanobakterien ein
Die durch Photosynthese Sauerstoff herstellen
Wir wissen, dass sie die Atmosphäre
Eines Planeten ziemlich schnell verändern können
Denn vor Milliarden Jahren
Waren sie vermutlich dafür verantwortlich
Das in der toxischen Atmosphäre
Der jungen Erde genug Sauerstoff
Für komplexe Lebewesen entstand
Na gut wir hatten ja viel Eisen im Meer
Wir hatten ja viel Eisen im Meer
Damals auf der Erde
So vor 3 Milliarden Jahren
Keine Ahnung
Aber nicht nur das
Cyanobakterien können auch Stickstoff
Aus der Atmosphäre binden
Und die Nährstoffe für Lebewesen umwandeln
Dadurch machen sie unseren toten Ozean
Fruchtbar
Und bereiten ihn für komplexere Organismen auf
Unsere Siedler an Land
Werden einen Teil der früheren Venus
Oberfläche zermahlen müssen
Um Erde herzustellen
In der Stickstoff bindende Pflanzen wurzeln können
Mit der Zeit bilden dann Milliardenbäume
Große Wälder
Die riesige Teile der Kontinente bedecken
Die Venus bekommt eine Flora
Zuerst in den Ozeanen dann auf Land
Um das etwas zu beschleunigen
Könnte extra CO2 für die Cyanobakterien
Also ich würde schon sagen
Das sieht gar nicht mal so schwer aus
Und wo etwas wächst
Schicken wir eine extra Portion Licht hin
In den Spiegeln in der Umlaufbahn
Damit die Pflanzen den größten Teil des Tages aktiv sind
Möglicherweise werden das auch
Pflanzen und Tiere sein
Die wir heute noch gar nicht kennen
Mit der Weiterentwicklung der Gentechnik
Und unserem wachsenden Wissen über Genetik
Können wir das Leben bis dahin
Vielleicht genau so konstruieren
Wie wir es brauchen
Alles in allem würde es mehrere tausend Jahre dauern
Bis Menschen die Atmosphäre atmen könnten
In der Zwischenzeit könntest du aber schon
In normaler Kleidung
Und mit einer Sauerstoffmaske
Einfach die ganze Welt entdecken
Die Siedler haben einen weiten
Komplett neuen Planeten
Volle Rohstoffe und Sonnenlicht zur Verfügung
Vielleicht finden sie eine neue Verwendung
Für die riesen Menge Kohlendioxid
Eis und Stickstoff in der Umlaufbahn
Industrielle Prozesse vielleicht
Sowas wie Raketenantriebe
Oder sogar das Terraformen
Eines anderen Planeten
Etwa des kleinen Mars
Jetzt ist Venus vollständig Terra geformt
Tiere streifen durch riesige Ökosysteme
Städte gebaut
Tadensiedler und ihre Nachkommen
Sind auf dieser Welt zuhause
Auf alten Bildern sehen sie
Wie Venus einst der lebensfeindlichste
Planet des Sonnensystems war
Wie es hunderte Jahre gedauert hat
Diese Hölle einzufrieren
Und die Ozeane zu schaffen
Und dann noch ein paar tausend mehr
Um freies Atmen zu ermöglichen
Sie werden es kaum fassen können
Na gut
Vielleicht ist es also gar nicht so einfach
Venus zu Terraformen
Damit sich dieser Zukunftstraum erfüllt
Aber es ist grundsätzlich möglich
Und zwar mit Technologien
Die eine motivierte
Nur etwas weiterentwickelte Menschheit
Erreichen könnte
Wenn sie ins All expandieren will
Die einzige wahre Grenze
Ist unsere Vorstellungskraft
Und wenigstens die
Sollte einfach zu überschreiten sein
Ich guck die Videos trotzdem gern
Wer reagiert denn auf der Venus
CDU
Gut
Der alte Zerstörer vielleicht
Da müssen wir uns aber ranhalten
So gucken wir noch irgendwas
Have you seen a better flank in Battlefield
Brandneue Armbrust
Links DevTools
Das ist ein gutes Video
Das kann ich jedem empfehlen
Guckt euch das nur mal an
Das ist mir aber zu deprimierend
Das Thema jetzt für den Stream
Auf Youtube
Wo ich mich so frage
Warum gibt es solche Channels
Was gucken wir denn
Wie viel Uhr haben wir denn
Oh ich bin 3 Stunden
Ich glaub ich krieg Hunger
3 zu 18
Ich krieg Hunger
Nicht Bett gehen
Alter
Ich war jetzt 3,5 Stunden wach
Jetzt kann ich wieder schlafen gehen
Intervall schlafen
Naja
So
Haben wir denn
Wer sich zu hosten lohnt
Ist der Frasier
Hm
Der starkste
Ich hoste ja am liebsten irgendwelche kleineren
Leute
Die ich aber selbst gucke
Da ist glaube keiner von
On gerade
Ah ne
Nein
Wir hosten keine
Pool Streamer
Wie sieht denn das eigentlich aus
Muss ich mal kurz gucken
Twitch
Tube
Hot
Wie heißt diese neue Kategorie überhaupt
Okay was gibt es denn da gerade
Ich hoste niemand von
Ah okay
Alles beim Alten
Wobei die ja für Twitch Verhältnisse noch relativ viel anhaben
Da habe ich doch schon weniger gesehen
Ähm
Gut also alles beim Alten
Gut wunderbar
Alles beim Alten wieder her
Heck wait
Äh wahrscheinlich Geschmackssache
Geschmackssache
Aber
Ich sehe es nicht ein
Selbst wenn ich sie hübsch finden würde
Was ich nicht beurteilen kann
Weil ich gucke mir das zu wenig an
Würde ich mir die Streams nicht angucken
Ich finde das Hot Tube Geschäftsmodell irgendwie fragwürdig
Harambe ist tot
Gut das hast du früh gemerkt
Dicks out for Harambe
Wie lange ist das her
3 Jahre 4 Jahre
Hot Tub
Hast recht
Hot Tube Hot Tub
Tab Tab klar
6 Jahre ist das schon her ach du Scheiße
Na gut
Also ich gehe auf ich gehe jetzt was essen
Gucken was noch da ist
Ich habe noch Nudel
Übrig mal gucken
Alles klar Leute wir sehen uns bis dann
See you